In this course, you will improve your HTML, CSS
and JavaScript skills by building a portfolio
website. Hello, everyone. In today's video, we're
going to be building a portfolio website using
HTML, CSS and JavaScript. So this is the main
homepage of the portfolio. Okay, so we have some
nice hover effects. On the buttons and images.
We can also toggle between light and dark theme.
Okay, so the next section is going to be the upper
section, we're going to have some information
with also nice after effects. And we're going
to have some stats here with progress bars.
And they're also going to have a timeline.
Okay, so it also looks nice on the light theme.
Okay, and then the next section is going to
be the portfolio section with an SRO effect,
one of these patterns can lead us to
any work suggests that you link it to,
okay, so for example, you want to get to GitHub,
you can click, and then it goes to GitHub,
or YouTube, whatever. Okay, and then the
next section is going to be the blog section.
We also have a nice hover effect
on images in the blog item. Okay.
Yeah, there it is. And then finally, we have
the contact section, you can put your contact
information here. Anything that you want, it's
up to you. This website is also responsive,
it's going to support multiple screens, you can
even make it more responsive as much as you want.
So when I decrease the width, it's going to check
those controls here, and then put them down here,
you can sort of, you know, switch between the
pages within the controls down here, instead of
them to be on the right side. Okay, so as you
can see, everything's going to respond nicely
to different screen sizes. Okay. So Sam is
the about is going to be NASA responsive.
And also the portfolio is
going to be nested responsive.
Yeah, also, everything is responsive. So
I'll show you everything out to make it
even more responsive, you have the knowledge to
make a difference. So yeah, I think that's it for
this quick demonstration. I'll see you in the
video. I have an images folder here. So there
isn't many images. So these are the images
that we're going to be using this project,
I'm going to start by creating a new HTML file,
index dot HTML, then I'm going to create a new
folder. So this one is going to be storing our
all of our styles inside the styles for them
when to create a new style. So the extension
we're going to be using for this one is s CSS.
So that's the sass preprocessor. It's much quicker
to do styles than normal CSS. So to be able to use
Sass, you need to go to the extensions, and
look for SAS, and then you're going to find
the SAS and then install that. And also, there's
a live compiler. So we don't need to restart every
time that we make updates to the code. So we can
just compile the code life. Okay. So now, I, you
might also want to download HTML CSS snippets. So
future HTML, CSS support, just install these two.
Okay, I think that's it for now, we just need
to go to the styles and let's do basic page
resetting. So I'm going to set the margin to
zero, because by default, the page is whenever
margin and padding zero, box sizing, zero
box, actually, box and then list style
to none. Okay, so in the body, I'm just
going to give it a background color of red
just to check out if our styles are working.
So we need to compile this Sass file into the
styles folder. So here you're going to see
a button says what Sass click the button.
Okay, and then it's going to generate a style css
file here. So let's go to the index and generate
HTML boilerplate. So to do that, hold Shift and
one and then click enter. Shift, hold Shift,
one, enter. Okay, so I'm going to
I'm going to name this portfolio.
Portfolio. Okay, so now I'm just going to link
the style css file styles. Start with CSS. So
I'm going to run this with live server. So you can
go to the extensions and look for live server plug
extension. Okay, so I'm going to
run this now. With the live server.
There it is. Okay, so that means our styles
are working. So I'm going to get rid of
the background color of red Margarida
that, I am going to actually get some fonts
first. Google Fonts, Google Fonts, I'm
going to get the font called Poppins.
Okay, so you need to select some font weights. So
we're going to be using regular 405 and 400 500,
the regular ones only, all the way to 800. So
once you've done that, you just need to copy this
link, once you've copied, go to the index below
the styles, and then paste in the Font weights.
Okay, so I'm also going to copy the font family
name, and then when I put it in the body.
Okay, so now that we've done the fonts, we're
going to be able to toggle between dark and light
mode. So to do that, we're going to be using some
variables, some CSS variables to to do variables,
we're going to type root, and then we're going
to put some variables inside the root. Okay,
so the mainly the variables
are going to do for the colors.
Okay, so you can do a variable literally for
anything from mainly in this video, I'm going to
do colors. So the first one is going to be color
primary. So this cover primary is going to be like
a dark color 191 And then D to B, I think that's
the color. Yeah. Okay, so that's the color, I'm
going to paste in the rest of the colors, because
I don't waste your time typing because one by one.
Okay, so these are the variables that we're
going to be using. So now, for the body,
I'm going to give it a background color.
So to be able to use the variable duva.
Primary, so VA primary color, we're going to
be utilizing this variable, which is a color a
dot one. Okay, so I went to also do a font size, a
default font size is going to be 1.1 RM. So that's
going to be our default font size. Also, I'm going
to give a different color, the default color is
going to be white. So by default on the text to
be white, okay, and then I want also a transition.
Transition. So the transition is going to
be all point four seconds is in a nice out.
Okay, so like that. So now that we've done that,
let's go to the index. So in here, I'm going
to give the body class of main content, so main
content, so that's the body. And then in the body,
we're going to have a header header with the class
of section. And then another class name of Section
sec, one, section one, and then another class
of header. And then it's going to have another
class of active, they want to see why we're using
active, I will explain as we go, we press enter.
Okay, so now if we had and
the underscore to your main,
in the main are going to
have session, dot section.
Section is going to have a class of section
and then doats, another class, section two,
and then another class about. Okay, so now I'm
going to click enter. So now we have a section.
Okay, so we're going to have five more sections.
Okay, so we have section, section two, about
some dessert, that's the class name, I'm going to
duplicate this. Tomato three more times 123. Okay,
so it's going to all of them are going to contain
a class of section, all of them. I'm just going
to change this from sector to sec three, section
four, and Section Five. Okay, you can just change
the class names here from about to portfolio.
And then the other one, this one's going to be
blogs. And then this one is going to be contact.
Contacts. Okay. So does that. Now we have the
sections, we need to, let's start by selling all
these sections. Before we add any content.
Let's work on the functionality to switch
between the sections, okay, using the JavaScript.
I'm going to introduce you to Font Awesome. I'm
going to say font, awesome CDN. CDN. And then look
for the Font Awesome CDN, look for the version,
version 5.5 point one, and then copy the
link tag, and then go below the Google Fonts
even above and then just paste in the link
Okay, so now we've pasted the link for font
awesome font, awesome. We can, you know,
like, sort of get icons from font awesome
font, awesome. Instagram, let's say we want
to use the Instagram icon. So we can copy this
Instagram icon, let's see if it's working, I'm
just gonna paste it down here. And when I save,
let's see in the preview if it's working or not.
Let's see, there it is. So that means
it's working. So it's white. So that's
the default color of the website. And the icon is
working. So that means what was some is installed
successfully. So now, let's start by installing
the sections, okay. Most of them are going to
target all of the links, the anchor tags,
I'm going to say, display, inline block,
nine block, and then text decoration
to none. And then I'm going to say
I'm going to actually give it was this I
forgot the name, color color is going to be
inherits we're going to inherit the color
we have in the body. And then font family
is going to be inherit inherited. Okay, so now
that let's go start each individual section.
So these sections are going to be able to switch
between the sections, because of the positioning
they're going to have, they're going to have a
percent of absolute. So each section is going to
have a minimum height of 100 VH. Okay, so that's
the minimum height and then a width of 100%.
And then we're going to do position of absolutes.
And then we're going to do left, zero, top to
zero is our top zero. And then we're going to do
padding. So padding spacing. So top and bottom,
the spacing between top and bottom is going to
be three RAM, and then 18 Ram left and right.
Okay, so each and every second is
going to have this this tiles, okay.
And actually, we need to also do the header.
So the head is going to have a height, a fixed
height of 100 VH. So the height for
the head is going to be fixed. Okay,
and then we're going to do a color, the color for
that is going to be white color. White for the
color. White, I don't know
why I didn't autocomplete.
And then we're also going to have an overflow
of hidden just in case something overflows.
Okay, so now, nothing happens. When I inspect
this, we have all of this, all of those sections
that are on top of each other. Okay, because
we're using position of absolute. So now they're
all laying on top of each other. So to create
the effect of switching between these sections,
we need a way to hide the rest of the sections and
then only display the one that we've clicked on.
Okay, we're going to do the light and
JavaScript. But now let's keep going.
I'm going to target a section class. So this
section class I'm going to do so by default,
I wanted to be away from this
screen, I wanted to be off screen.
Okay, so I'm going to use a transform for that
for that. And then I'm going to translate to y
minus one represent. Because by
default only to be off screen.
Okay, and then I'm also going to do a transition,
you can create a variable for this transition
actually, if you want, because we're going to
reuse this a lot of times in this video. So
you can, you know, make it easier by creating a
variable for that. Okay, so now we've transition.
And also we need the background color. So for
this one is going to have a VA primary color.
Primary color, okay, so that's, that's the
one. So each individual sections, we can style
them differently, we can give them a different
background color, a different whatever. So I'm
going to tag a section one, sec, one, sec one. So
this one, you can give it a different background
color if you want to, by by by default only to be
none the display. I don't want to display anything
because I want to be able to switch between these
sections. Okay, I'm going to do transform as all
translate. Translate Y sheets, y one to translate
y zero for now. And then we're going to do scale.
We're going to do one. Okay, so now, when we the
second is active, is going to come back to the
default place. So here we did transform, Translate
Y minus 100% and scale which is zero here. So once
we come back to the default place is going
to you know, it's going to make like an
animation coming in, off screen and scaling
all the way to one So this scale works from
one, zero to between zero, and one. Okay, so we
need to do this for the rest of the sections.
So I'm just going to paste in some code for the,
for the rest of the sections. So this sections,
each individual section, you can give
it a different background color. Okay,
you can kind of, you know, give it a different
background color, just to see your to your liking.
Okay, nothing much, nothing much happens here,
nothing much. So now for now, let's, let's do the
buttons, which are going to let us control these
sections. So this buttons, I'm going to do dot
controls. So make sure controls pressure, this
is the wrong spelling, well, it doesn't matter.
So inside the controls, we're going to have
the buttons, okay, so each individual button
is going to have a class of control. So
I'm going to do Dutch Control. Control.
So that's a button is going to have a control.
And then it's going to have control one. So the
first one's going to be control one, the
second one control to control three, and
so on. So I'm going to say, control. So this one
is Ctrl. One, I'm going to use the dollar sign.
So the dollar sign means increment the numbers
automatically, depending on how many classes on
how many divs we've created. Okay, so control,
and then it's going to have another class of
actually is not going to win any other
class. And yeah, I'm just going to hit enter
a play, I'm just going to put a class
of active BTN. So that's the first one
is going to have a class of Active button,
I'm going to multiply this by five. Okay,
so we don't need the Active button on the rest of
the diffs. Okay, so thinking like get rid of this
will only want the first one to have active
buttons. So we have control, control one,
control two, three, all the way to five. Okay,
so inside each of these divs, I'm going to put
a corresponding icon. So in this case, you can go
to Font Awesome, and then you can, for example,
search, let's say, home, you can look for an icon
that you're looking for, in this case, this one,
and then you just gonna copy this, and then
you paste it in, like so. So that's the icon
we're looking for. This is going to paste in
the this data instead of me doing number one.
Okay, so we are using a warm briefcase newspaper
envelope open, agree to this one later.
Okay, so now, I'm going to save this, as you can
see with the icons there. So for us when these
icons will be here on the right side. So to do
that, we're going to be using position of fixed
because we need to be at a fixed position.
Okay, so we're going to target the controls.
You can make a comment here, say controls,
controls, and then here, you just do control
dirt control. Okay, so this is the parent.
So position, we're going to do person a fixed,
so that's the parent container, and then Z index
is going to be 10 was only to be always at
the top. And then I'm going to do top 50%.
Okay, and then right is going to be 3%. So
when did you be aligned to live space of 3%
from the right. So there they are. So now
the living 3% of space from the right side.
Okay, so now we're going to do display, flex, flex
direction, column. And then we're also going to,
I think we might be able to give him a font size
some sometime later, but I want to actually send
this in the y axis. So to center this in the
y, we can do transform, Translate Y minus 50%
to center this in the y so as I
save, as you can see there, they now
they've updated, they've now nicely
centered. Okay, so we've kind of
centered, I'm going to do align items
to center, and then just for content
to center as well. Okay, so I'm going
to target the control class control.
Control class. So for the control class, I'm
going to give it a padding, so it's like spacing
around it. So the spacing is going to be one room
and then a cursor is going to be pointer. Okay,
so pointer and then I'm going
to give it a background color.
Background color is going to be
so it's going to be for grateful.
So it's going to be grateful. So that's the
background color. So width and height is going
to be 55 pixels because I want it to be rounded.
So within it has to be the same, we want to make
something rounded. So the border radius is
going to be 50% to make them rounded. Okay,
so as you can see now the rounded, but I want
to center these icons that are centered nicely.
So to do that, we're just going to use flex,
it's easy display, flex and align and just for
content to center, okay, so I'm also going to make
a spacing between these icons. So the spacing that
we're going to use is margin. So top and bottom
is going to be point four 0.7, Rem, and then zero,
left and right. Okay, also, we're going to give
a box shadow box shadow, we might also want to
put this box shadow in a variable, to be honest.
I'm gonna create a here I'm gonna say, folks,
Shadow shadow one. And then these are the values
or zero on the x axis, three pixels on the Y
15 pixels for the blur and then the opacity is
0.3. Okay, so this is the processor that we're
gonna be using. And this is going to do over,
and then I'm just gonna paste in the variable,
just in case we don't like redo this picture,
because I want to be reusing this bookseller a lot
in this video. Okay, so they're, they're showing
nicely. So I want to also resize this icon,
the icon size. So to do that, I'm going to
target the eye, which is the eye inside the icon.
If you don't already know about Sass, we can nest
in the elements. Okay, so we can nest some HTML
elements. So that's what I'm doing right now.
So I'm gonna say font size, I'm gonna put this
to 1.2. Rem, I want it to be slightly bigger.
And then I'm going to also give it a color,
and pointer events of none. So pointer
events, it means I want to, if when I click,
I don't need to do anything, it doesn't react to
the click, or to the mouse, whatever. Okay, so now
with let's save, everything looks nice. Everything
looks on point. Okay, so now, I'm going to,
so if you remember, here, I've given this a
class of Active button. So the whatever button,
I want this active class, to be applied
to whatever element that I've clicked on,
and also, at the same time, remove
other elements with that class,
okay, so when I click this, on only this button
to have that class action button, Active button,
and then remove the remaining active buttons,
class names. So that definitely that feature is a
little bit tricky for you know, for beginners,
but it's actually easy to do. So what we're
going to do now, actually, I'm going to tell the
Active button first. So whatever Active button,
so in here, above the control, I'm gonna
say, dots, active version, I'm going to
stop that. So it's just giving it a
background color and the transition.
Okay, like, so background color is going to be
the secondary color, which is the green color.
And then I'm going to toggle the icon
inside the eye. So I'm gonna just
target the icon and give it a color of white.
Okay, so there it is. So that's the Active button.
It seems like everything is nicely centered now.
Yeah, so now the Active button is going to be
green. Okay, so now that actually
button is green, we just need to
go to the JavaScript. And let's create
a new JavaScript file, actually.
So let's do new file, it's going to be up
to j s. So this object is going to select
some HTML elements. So I'm going to select all
items or elements using the section class. So
const sections document query selector, query
selector, all everything that says the class
of section. So remember, we've given all of the
sections the class of section, so it means I'm
selecting everything with the class of section.
So I'm targeting this. I'm also going to select
I'm also going to select the bad
section buttons. So the second buttons
is the parent container of this of these buttons.
So the controls so these are the section buttons,
so it's like the parent, I'm selecting this
parent container, and then inside and we're
to also select the each individual button with
a class of control. Okay, so I'm just going to
Okay, so there is a second button controls. So
this is the parent This is the actual button
I'm also going to select the body, the body is
a class of main content. So there is the body
main content, that's the class. Okay, so in
here, I'm just going to create a new function.
I'm going to use the function function to create a
new function. And then we'll say page. Transition
transitions. Maybe we can name this function,
whatever you want. It's up to you, really. So now,
we're going to come in here, I'm going
to say, button. Click, active class.
Active class. Okay, so what, what do I
want to happen when I click the button?
So this, I want to be able to get rid of the class
that is not active, only the active class, that's,
that's what I want to have the class one. So
we're going to do a loop, we're going to do four.
So we're going to do let we're going to
create a new variable. So let i Okay,
so it's going to be initially set to zero and then
we're going to say i is less than as long as i
is less than is less than the length, the length
of the button, okay? To section BTN. Session btn
is this one. Okay, so as long
as the is i is less than that.
We're going to increment increment.
Alright, so now does that.
So in here, I'm going to say,
sick person button. So the second set
button is meant to look for the index,
the eye. Okay, whatever index we're on.
And then I'm going to say it goes through.
Actually, I'm going to add an event
listener to whatever index we've
clicked on. So this is Is this the index? Okay,
so I'm going to say dot add event listener.
So the event listener is going to take two.
The first one is going to be click, and then the
second one is going to be a callback function.
So what am I doing? This one is going to be a
cubic function. So in in this callback function.
Okay, so in this case, I'm going
to select the current button,
whatever button was clicked on the current
button, you can button well on current
BTN. And then I'm going to say is close to
document. So we're going to do query selector
with a class of Active button, okay, so if you
remember, the buttons are going to have a class of
active BTN. Okay, so I'm selecting that it's, it's
with the name of current button. So I'm going to
say current button. The first one, with an index
index of zero, I'm going to say to a class name,
then I'm going to say current btn index zero, then
I'm going to do class name, I'm going to not list
class name. And then I'm going to replace that
with an empty string. Once we're out of the
ones, it's not active, active, B, TN, and then
I went to replace with an empty string. Okay, so
whatever button clicked on, when we're not
letting clicking it anymore, we're going to
go to the class and press the empty string. So
here, I'm going to do this dot class name. So
this is referring to this function. Okay, so
this is like a confusing topic to learn about the
this keyword in JavaScript. So kind of
weird. And then I'm going to do plus equal to
active person, active BTN.
Like that. So now, when I save,
we need to call this function, page
patients patients. So let's go the
function. Let's go actually worse, I need to
link this JavaScript file, going to scripts.
Scripts, and then we'll go to source and then up
to j s. Then let's save save everything and then
go to the page inspect. And then when we click
this button or free a class you should appear
on whatever button have clicked on. And then it's
going to get rid of this activity. pattern here.
Okay, that's a stat. We have
an error. But we're going to
say it didn't work. So when I click the class is
off, but it's not working. Let me inspect what's
going on. Canary properties of undefined class
name. Okay and prefers the this one. This keyword.
Class Name to replace. Okay, something is wrong
class list. Oh, this no cloud is supposed to be
class name, not list. Okay, so let's save this.
Hopefully, issue work, click. Nothing
happens we have an error again.
undefined. That's weird. Current btn class name
replace active BTN. So you just need to make
sure let me double check, maybe just double
check to see if the namings are correct. I'm just
going to copy and paste and replace everything
except Well, I think the naming is correct.
Okay, let's try to figure out what's going on.
Undefined current button
at evaton Okay, the, the class naming is correct.
Document query selector. All don't
get what, what? Undefined here
I just realized something I didn't I didn't find
the error, but must have supposed to use an arrow
function here. I'm pretty sure. I'm supposed to
use a regular function. I'm gonna do function
like that, instead of, because this keyword
doesn't exist in in an arrow function.
Okay, so it only exists on the regular
function. Oops, why did I click? OK, so
let me just show you from recording.
Only right after I stopped the video,
that's when I realized that I've used the
error function. Okay, so when I go to console,
okay, everything works fine. So now it's working
as expected. Only, so Jenny's error functions for
the, if you want to use the this keyword doesn't
exist in arrow functions. Okay. So now let's,
let's move on to the next step to the next step.
So for the next stage, let's touch actually doing
the content. But to be able to do that we need
to be able to cycle between these sections.
Okay, so now we've done the active class for
the button. So now we need to do the content. So
each button is going to have something
called a data data ID. And then this data ID.
So when I click the button is going
to look for a section with this ID.
So in this case, it's going to look for the
about section with an ID of about portfolio about
portfolios, blogs, and contacts. So make sure you
add the data ID next to the next to the code to
the class after the class. And then here I'm going
to also add a data ID so this one is going to be
the header so this one is going to
look for the header. Actually, we can
do main, a home. It's up to you home.
Okay, so I'm gonna give the IDs so do ID.
So this one is going to be home so give the
Christmas Id make sure this ID matches the data
ID here. So for the home, the first one, the first
pattern is going to be home. The second is about
about. So this section about section, one, two ID,
ID, so this one is going to be about,
and then this third one, ID, Port
folio, then Id, this one is going to be
blogs. And then finally, we have contact,
ID, contact. Okay, so these IDs are going
to help us navigate through these sections.
Okay, so now that we have those IDs,
we've done these sections, let's
let me inspect this section.
They're there, but they're right
on top of each other. For the main,
the sections that are there, actually, we need
to style these out different background colors.
Okay, you know what we want to give them different
background color, background color, slate blue,
so you can see the difference,
but we don't see them yet. Because
there's a scale scale is zero. And actually
translate is minus 100%. So they're off screen,
and the scale is zero as
well. So you don't see them
yet, so we just need to do a little bit of
JavaScript. So we'll be able to see them later on.
Alright, just for you to see these sections.
Okay, I'm going to save this. So we don't
see these sections. Now we just need to
do the active class. So when we click each
button is going to do an active class. Okay,
so the active class is going to be
the active class is going to be added
to the sections. Okay? So here, I'm going to
say sections. Active class. Okay, so we have all
sections, we are selecting all of these sections
here. So this section is targeting. So this,
the main content here is the body. Okay, so the
body. That's the all of this section is like a
parent of all of these sections. So I'm going
to say, all a section, all of these sections,
dot for each, so I'm going to loop over whatever
is inside the body. Okay. So in this case,
all of the sections are inside the body. So
it's going to take in a callback function, I'm
going to say section. Okay, so we have section,
actually, we need to add an event listener,
we'll look through later add event listener. And
then when I click inside, what's the trick? Okay,
so you can do your cover function here, and then
we'll go into an event. So the E is for the event.
Okay, so I'm going to, I'm just going to say
E, control log here, I'm going to say e dot
target. Okay, so I'm going to save, let's go to
the console, let me just click anywhere. So it's
not doing anything yet, because the sessions are
outside. Okay, so you won't, you won't, you won't
see it. But now it's targeting whatever element of
its console logging element that I've clicked on,
as you can see, and then it's showing the
class or whatever element in the name of
development have clicked on. Okay, so we're just
adding event listener to whatever element but
in this case, we want to target these buttons
here. Okay, so let's get rid of this. So in here,
I want to say const. ID. And then we're
going to say is cost to e to a target
dot data set data set like this and then.id.
So the data set is like referring to whatever.
I've clicked on whatever element have clicked on
the target, what going to target the data set.
So the data set is this one here. Get a data ID
here. So whatever element that I've clicked on,
I want to target the data sets, whatever element
I've clicked on, especially these buttons,
I want to get the data set for that. So I want
to get take the names of these data sets here.
Okay, so that's what this is referring to. So
I'm like taking the data set and put it into a
variable called ID. Okay, so I'm going to say, if,
if this was true, or if we have an ID, whatever
we're going to do, we're going to first remove the
Remove, selected, selected from the other button.
Okay, that's something like that.
So am will do section buttons,
which is the container of the buttons. But I want
to look through each individual button inside.
Okay, so to do that, we're just going
to do with for each, so each button
so for each button, I'm going to do by btn is
button to a class this class list and then I'm
going to remove the class of Active button active
actually, active active button is a different
class for the styling of the buttons. But this is
a class referring to. So this active class, we're
going to use this for the sections, not the active
styles like this. So this this different thing,
different class name. Okay, so we're looping
through the button, each individual button.
If we click New button, we're just getting getting
rid of the class. And then we're just going to say
eat or target. And then we're going to say class
list, we just want to add the class to whatever
button that was clicked on. So here, we're
just going to do either target or classless
the is gonna is coming from here the event.
Okay? So we're going to add a class of active.
Okay, so now that we've added the class,
I'm also going to hide other sections.
Other sections. So as we're doing, so
we've done that already, but like, I'm just
gonna do that sections. So this, we're
not seeing the sections yet. But when I
click the Active button, I want to be able to
set the display and the transcript translate
translation to default. Okay,
so I'm going to do sections.
I'm going to do that for each section. So
if you remember, the sections is coming
here from the section. So it's every second
I'm looking through every section. Okay, so
for every section, I'm gonna say a section, I'm
gonna section the class list. Now add or remove,
it's like the same thing that we've done with
the button. I'm going to say active. Alright, so
that's pretty much it actually done. Yeah, I'm
just gonna do one more thing, constant elements.
element, and then you're
just going to do document.
document. And then we're going
to do dot get element by ID,
element by ID. And then we're going
to pass in the ID. So whatever ID
is coming from the data set is going to be inside
the element, element variable, we're saving the
ID. So remember, here we give we give the ID here,
Id about portfolio. So whatever element we're on,
we're going to pass in the ID. And also this data
ID is it's linked to the to these IDs. So whatever
element we're on, and then we're targeting the
ID. So now we're just going to say element.
You can name and then we'll do Class and
Class List. And then also just going to add
active. Okay, so now I'm going to save let's
see what we have. So let's inspect to see
our sections. So, home hopefully should have an
active class header. We've added this manually,
but when I click something else, hopefully
should get rid of this and put it somewhere else.
When I click Yep, it got rid of the activity.
Last from the header, now this one is active.
These about when I click, this one is active now
is getting rid of the existing class on other.
Okay, so now we can only use the active on one
element. But we don't see our sections here. They
are there, but we don't see them. Because they're
hidden, we just need to display those sections.
So I'm going to go under Search SEC five, I'm just
going to do dot active. So it's telling the active
display block, so we only want to
display whatever element is active. Okay.
Now, let's say so now the head is active, it has a
color of green. It's working. Okay, so everything
works. We can cycle through the sections.
Okay? But this sections, they're not animating?
No, no, that's not what we want.
So down here, I'm just gonna say,
animation. I'm gonna say scale. And
him. So that's never the animation,
the duration is going to be one second. And then
we're going to have an ease in and ease out.
So I'm going to do an animation down
here. I'm going to do it keyframes,
and then this one is going to be scale. And him.
So that's the name of the animation scaler name.
And then I'm going to do at 0% What we
want is zero, transform, translate. France,
late transformed, transform, translate 0%.
Translate Y. Okay, so for the Y here is
the same thing we've done before. Scale,
zero. Okay, so it's only gonna
have two states, the 10% 0% and the
100%. Okay, what's my maths is broken, by the
way, he double clicks when I don't need to.
So when I tried to do a single click in double
clicks automatically, and to get a new mouse,
okay, so here is just resetting the values to
back to zero and the scaled that to one. Okay,
let's save this. Hopefully it should
work. Now. As you can see, we can scale.
Okay, we can see, but that's not the effects
we're looking for. We are looking for Scale Y.
Okay, so we're looking for Scale Y.
Okay, we run the scale everything. So we want
only to scale the Y axis. So when the content
come from, you know, up. As you can see,
now we can, you know, do those effects.
Okay, that's it for the effects now can
scrub through the sections. I'm going to
take a break now. And then I'll be back in a
way, I'm just gonna drink some water. And then
we'll continue where we left off. Okay,
I'm back. So now let's do the header. So
let's throw the header to the content, insert the
header and then we'll move on to other sections.
So for the header, we're only mainly
going to have some images and stuff.
So here, I'm going to do a class header content.
So the header content is going to have a left
hand side and the right left header and then
we're going to have the right header so the
right side. So those are going to display grid.
Okay, so for the left side is there's there is
nothing anything here is just an image. We're
going to do header shape. And then below that
want to do an image is inside image TIFF. IMG,
IMG hero, does the image name and then go to
the right side. So here's just a bunch of text.
So we're gonna have h1, with name.
I'm just gonna paste in the name
Okay, so this pan is surrounding the name
because I want to color this color in the
Name the only this bit a different color
that I'm surrounding with this pan.
Okay, so this pan or save a class of name, I
don't know I have the same, I'm gonna get rid
of the span class, class name is gonna sound
like this expand. Okay. Below that, we're
gonna have a p a p tag, who I'm just going
to paste in some text as well. I'm sorry,
I'm sorry for the background noise, my mates
I playing a video game when I do a dot, main,
main BTN. Okay, so that's an anchor
tag. So it's going to have an icon.
And it's going to have two spans, this is
the first pan, it's going to have a class
of btn text. Okay, so it's just
text, the text gonna say download CV,
you can put any text that you want. So this
an anchor tag is a link, you can make it go
somewhere, or to Google Drive, wherever you're
saving your CV, or whatever, you can send it
there. And then another span is going to have an
icon for the download icon come from Font Awesome.
Okay, so now that's it for the header
content, we just need to do the styles,
I'm going to get rid of this green color here.
So that was just for testing purposes for you
to see, to show you that the sections are
working, I'm just going to get rid of this
guy read when I get rid of every thing. Okay,
so now we're left with the default colors.
So now let's touch doing the
header. So for the header content.
After the controls, I'm just
gonna say header content
and the content and then I'm gonna do
another duplicate this, I'm gonna say
in the content components, so some
components that we might want to reuse,
we're gonna put them down here. Okay, so
now, I'm going to target header content.
Header content. So for the other content, we're
going to do display of the grid, we're going
to put two column grid, grid template columns,
we're going to do repeat, so one to two columns,
and then one Fr. So they're all going to be
equal. So when I save, so now we have two columns,
when I inspect this, as you can see, we have two
columns, one, two. Okay, so that's what we want.
And then yeah, the height is going to be one or 2%
with the height, and then I'm going to target the
left header, left hander. So for that display,
flex, align items, align items relative to center.
Okay, and then position is going to be relative
because when to position absolute a shape,
that's going to be behind our image. So this image
save this is going to have a shape behind it.
Okay, so that's why we're doing the
person relative the parent container.
So the shape we've named that shape, ah,
shape, if you remember, just the header shape,
the shape is going to have a transition
that we've been using before,
I'm just going to paste in transition and then a
height of one represent with 65%. The wrong color
is going to be far, it's going to be secondary
color, it's going to be the background color,
and then position absolute, and then
we're going to do left, zero, top zero,
top zero. And then we're going to do Z
index wanted to be behind the image of one
minus one actually wanted to be behind. And
then I'm going to do clip path. So clip path,
I'll show you what, what he does, I'll just
paste in the corner and then I'll show you.
So this is the clip path, these are the
values are using the clip path is like
altering the shape. So to do that, we can do clip
path generator. And then we can generate kind of
a clip path. For example, then this trapezoid,
trapezoid the name, it's kind of confusing to
read. And then we can you know, generate the shape
that we're looking for. And then you can just copy
this code and then you can paste it wherever on
whatever shapes want to customize. So in this
case, these are the, these are the values that
I'm using. And then after that after the shape,
I'm going to target the image. So for the
image, I'm going to give it a border radius.
So the border radius is going to be VA, I'm going
to do MD, I can't remember the border radius.
Small, too. So missing the border radius mod two
is a variable. Okay? When I do width, and height,
so it is going to be 90%, height 100, height
90% with 68%. And then I'm big on color,
background color is going to be far. So the
background color is going to be black. That's
going to be the background color, and then the
transition when the transition. So we've used
this transition multiple times, and then I'm going
to edit the image. Inside the image container,
we have an image, the actual image, width
and height is going to be set to 1%.
Okay, and then object fit to cover so it doesn't
stretch out of the feet to cover. So this image is
going to stretch out, we also want to transition
this image again, copy this transition we're
going to read you can put that into a variable,
so you don't have to copy and paste like this.
And then want this image to be in a grayscale for
someone say future grayscale. And then I'm going
to put the guilt, Grace, grayscale to 100%. Then
when we have when we have the image and hover.
So this is the beauty of sass, we
can nest components, HTML elements,
and then we're going to set filter. grayscale,
zero. Okay, let's save. Let's see what we get.
Okay, so when I have the image is changing color.
Alright. Doesn't get rid of these. So now yeah,
leave me cynical. So now let's go to
the right side. So on to the right side.
It's mainly, so we have left header, I'm going to
collapse the left header. I'm going to save right
header. Okay, so for the right header, and when
I do display flex, display this play flex, flex
direction to column because I want everything to
be in a column direction. Okay, and then just for
content to center, and then padding right? To put
a large value here, hmm, I think that works name,
then font size. So for the name is the main
title, I'm going to make it bigger. Okay,
and then I'm going to target this pan inside
it. So there's a span in there. So this pan is
gonna have a color, different color, the color,
this color is going to be a secondary color.
Secondary, so via secondary color. So that's
the color of that. And then after the name,
we have a paragraph, I'm going to give them
margin, top and bottom is going to be 1.5 Ram.
And then left or right is going to be zero.
And then after that, I'm going to give you the
line height. So line eight is the spacing of
lines of text. So the letter is going to be
sort of like something like that I'm
going to save let's see what we get.
So there it is. Looks nice. So we just need to
start this pattern. So to start the button, we're
going to reuse this button so it's independent
component. So I'm going to say dot main btn Okay,
so this main btn actually, it's I think it's
wise to put it into a container dot btn container
like that. Okay, so now we can try to can
start styling the main button. Okay, so
this button is going to have a lot of styles.
Okay. So border radius is going to be 30 pixels.
Wanted to be nicely rounded,
not that not 20 by 30. Okay
font size. We'll do color. Inherit
and then we're going to font weight,
it's going to be 600 on the text to be thick.
Okay? And then I'm going to do percent of well
And then I'm going to give you a border
with one pixel and the color of secondary.
That's the border, I'm going to do display flex
and align everything to center. Okay, and then
I'm going to say overflow to hidden. Okay. So
inside the button, we have btn text or BTN.
Text, and then I'm just going to give it a
padding, top and bottom zero to REM left or right.
Okay, so in the button, we also have,
we also have dot btn, we have the icon.
Okay. Btn icon. So if you don't remember the class
names, this one btn icon. Okay, so the btn icon,
it's gonna have a color of a green color,
secondary and then sent, everything is in
Flex. Okay, so we've done that over and over. So
sometimes I'm just gonna have to copy and paste.
So to set everything just display flex
align items center justify content center.
So padding while RAM, so it's like spacing around.
I'm gonna save let's see what we got. So there's
our button, but it's filling in the entire width,
because we're using flex on the parent container.
So to get rid of this effect, we can do btn
can be tn container, if you remember, to put in
the apparent container called BT and corn. Here,
there it is, between corn, we're just going to do
display flex on that display. Flex. And then we're
going to say align self. Pressure. Sure. flexter.
Yeah. So now now now we need to have an bring in
something here when you have an bringing like a
shape that similar to a button. So we're going to
use a pseudo pseudo element before pseudo element,
we'll say end for four. And then we're
going to say content to an empty string.
So we can start this to whatever
styles we desire. Pacino salutes top 00
And then write is going to be zero. Right
zero, and then we're going to do transform,
Translate X. So we're going to take the shift away
from the button, man, as well as the percent is
going to go like to the side away from the
button, man as one of the percent. We're also
going to do the transition. I'm just going
to paste in the transition. And then I'm
going to do Z index wanted to be behind the
text of the button, and as one okay. So now
this shape is there, but it doesn't have a width,
height, anything defined. So I'm going to say and
hover when I have the button. Have the button
and we're taking the before pseudo element.
What do I need to oil What do I want to happen?
I'm going to put your width and height 100%
And then the set a background
color to the secondary color.
Okay, so now when I inspect, let me
inspect this. Let's look for the before
is there the before suderman Is there, but
remember we are translating on the x axis minus
one represent so we need to bring it back
to the default position which is zero. Okay,
when we have and then when we are not having
it's going to go back to away from the button.
String A which is doing this effect from the wrong
direction. So it's it's from minus it's actually
100% Because we're going one 2% On the positive
value minus is gonna go negative. Okay,
so I wanted to amend positive so it's coming from
the right side now. So see, but yeah, there it is.
I think we need to add a transition somewhere. In
here, too. We need to transition here so somewhere
safe. Safe scratch I don't know
it's glitching sometimes glitches
not doing it before transition. I think in the
hover, that's when we need to transition, let's
say start doing it. If it doesn't does, if it
doesn't work, it doesn't look smart in the icon
Okay, doesn't matter, but works. Okay, so now
what we need to do is go on to the next section,
which is the about section. This ABA section, it's
a it's a, it's just, I just say it's too much.
So much content there. Okay, so
I'm just gonna go to the About
About me check how long I've been recording,
I'm so tired. I've recorded this video like
a couple of times, and then I made an error
which was too bad I couldn't even edit out so
now I'm going to go to the
About section so on to the
Mac labs the controls about in there about I'm
going to create a new div called main title.
So we want to be able to reuse this title
was to so this is like a title this pan
inside it's like the main title. So we have
about me and then we have a span covering the me.
Okay, so when to color this differently.
So we first learning something with span,
it means we're going to style that difference
test that particular element differently.
Okay, so in the independent components, so we
finished the button now on to do main title.
Alright, so, for the maintainer.
It's just the text align to center.
text align to center, and then now
we're going to tie to the edge to the
header position relative and then we're
going to do text transform, uppercase.
Swap uppercase, and then we're going
to do font weight, font size first
forum. font weight is going to be 700. And
then that's it for now, let's tidy this pans.
So for this pan, I'm gonna do color, it's going
to be VA, it's gonna be a secondary color.
Okay, so after that we're gonna target PG, PG text
so the big Tex is going to a position
of absolute is going to be like behind
the main test. I'm going to say top
50% And then we're going to do lifts
50% as well. And then we're going to do
color, a gray color and then the transition
okay, I'm just going to paste in so transition
is usually Z index minus one I want it to be
behind the text Okay, and then the font
weight 800 So this transform translate
minor C to cinema suit percent it means when to
send or something. Okay? And then the font size
is going to be 6.3 Ram. Okay, let's
save this. Let's see what we get.
Okay, so there it is. Okay, so about me
then yes is my stats in the background.
Okay, so now we have the
main title, the big title.
Now let's to talk about content. So it's
like a div that's gonna contain everything
about container container, and then I'm gonna have
a left container left about in the right about
left and right. Okay, so we're going to have an h4
in the paragraph. I'm just going to paste this. So
on the left about, okay, that's what we're
starting with h4 In a paragraph h4 Is the heading.
Okay? And then I'm going to copy that button
again, the button that we've used in the header.
Okay, so below, below the paragraph, I'm going to
put the button the button container main button.
Okay, I'm just reusing the baton. I'm going to
save this. So there it is. So we're reusing this
same button over and over again. I think that's
good. Okay, so on the right side, right about
I'm going to collapse this pattern. And
then I'm gonna collapse this paragraph.
And then I'm going to be left with the ratable.
So in here, and we're just gonna say talked about
item. Okay, so the bot item is going
to have a class of dots, a B, T.
Text. Okay, so in here, we're just gonna have a p
p dot large text. Okay, I'm going to say
maybe 650 or 560 Plus projects. Okay.
So here, I'm just going to paste in
another paragraph, the class of small,
small text, and then we're going to
the neuron line br It means Break,
break the line, go to the new line. And then
yeah, we're just breaking the text. Okay,
so that's it for that. So mainly, on the right
about, we're just going to have like, a grid.
Okay, so we're gonna go independent
components, I'm gonna say here
about Okay, so in here, I'm going to say,
about container. So in about
container, I'm gonna do display,
display grid. Then grid, template columns,
also repeats, I'm gonna have two columns.
Two, and then one EFA. They're
all going to equal sizes.
And then I'm going to do padding top and
padding bottom of, I'm just going to paste
in this. So it's a no brainer, padding, top
345 padding, bottom left and right about.
Okay, so on the right about, it's also going
to be a grid. Okay, display grid, then grid,
somebody columns, so this one is going to be
TFT. Same thing. Repeat two columns, one Fr.
Like that. And then below that, we're going to do
grid gap. So it's like spacing between grid items.
We gap when the term so that's
like the spacing between two items.
Okay. Now, let's save. Let's go there. So that's
the about item, there it is. The write about item,
we just need to keep starting. Okay, so we're
going to talk about item, I will give it a border
one pixels on pixel, and a border radius and
a transform and shadow, the ones we've been
using for one pixel and the color of gray.
Okay, so And however, when we have this
when we have a, I'm just going to say cursor
to default. Okay, and then I'm going to say
transform, translate, I won't translate y
minus 50 minutes left, minus five fixes.
Minus five pixels, I want to have and then goes
up. So that's the kind of effect I'm looking
for. And then the border, I'm going to change
the border color from primary to secondary.
And then the box shadow. I'm just
going to increase the intensity,
the opacity Okay, so from open one to open
three, two. Okay, I'm going to save this
go to the About section. So there it is. So
now we have a border surrounding you only
have it turns green. Okay, so below that,
below the hover. We're going to do the about
text the vertex, okay, so padding. Padding
1.5 REM Now we're going to do is display flex,
display to flex. And then we're also
going to change the direction to column.
Alright, so now we're going to look for large
text. So the left text, I'm just going to change
the font size to three REM font weight to 700.
And then we're also going to change the color,
color Tuva, secondary Saundra color.
Okay, and then now we're going to target
the small text. For this small text, I'm
just going to have padding, left of three REM
through RAM, and then when to position
of relative, and then text transform
text transform to uppercase, so I wanted the
text to be in uppercase. And then when do font
size 1.2 REM then the color is going to be gray.
And then late letter spacing, letter spacing,
I want these to be two pixels and then end
I'm going to give it a before pseudo element.
So it's going to be like a small
line. Okay, with a person of absolute,
I'm just gonna paste in the code for that. So the
content empty string person absolute left zero,
top 250 pixels with two RAM, high two pixels,
I'm going to save this. Okay, so there it is.
So this is the before pseudo element, the
literal line here, I'm gonna inspect this.
So there it is. Okay, so this is a grid, where
we have two columns here. So we need three more
objects here. For us to have like four items.
So you can clone this grid items here you can
about item, you can clone this three more
times 123, safe, and then just change the
data to whatever data fits your need. So
there it is. So now we have more items.
For me to change every item here, I'm not going to
do that, I'm just going to paste in the items that
I've changed the data already. So I don't want
to waste your time changing the information about
these items. I'm just going to paste in all of the
items that with data down to them already. Okay,
so the idea of like sort of already feeding
the data. So now let's go to the left side.
Okay, so this is the right about.
And then what to do at dusk.
About so left about is just there isn't
much in there. So we're going to do
padding, right? Padding, right it's going to
be from from, and then one tag at a p tag,
line height. So the line height for this p
tag, I'm going to set it to two REM Azhar
and then we're going to do padding
top and bottom is going to be our RAM
or RAM, and then the color is going to be
gray one. Okay, that and then I'm going to
tell you the h4 is just putting into uppercase the
text, the h4 and then the container of the button.
Actually Do I need to tell you the container,
the button just save everything should
be nice already. There it is. So everything
it looks nice. We are about. So now we just
need to add more, more stuff below here. So we
have like progress bars in the timeline stuff.
So let's just do that. Now. So let's go
to the HTML. I'm going to collapse the the
about container I'm going to collapse that. So
now I just want to sort of like add the stats, the
I'm gonna do about stats first, that's okay. So
in here the bus stats nothing much nothing much
is going on here. Just an h4 Seeing my skills.
And then when I create a class called progress
progress bars, the div, program, progress
bars and then another div called progress.
Bar. Progress Bar. Okay, so that's another
class. In there, we have a title called P.
Progress. Title. Okay, so that's a P progress
title, I'm going to say HTML five for this one.
Okay. And then below that, we're
going to have progress container.
Okay, so in there, we're going to we're going
to have like the progress text, P does Frog,
frog text. So this is the text, it's going to be
like 80% or 90, it's up to you what whatever with
whatever percentage of your skill. So in this
case, I can just say maybe 90%. That's like a p
tag. And then below that, I'm gonna have a cluster
progress. So this is the actual progress bar.
And then in this whenever span, and then the
class for this plan is going to be actually M L.
Okay, so that's that for the so this is the
progress bar item. We can duplicate this many
times as many, depending on how many progress
bars you want to do. Okay, so now let's just
go to the styles. So about container. After
that, I'm just going to say dot about stats.
Above stats. So here, I'm just gonna do padding
bottom to forum was I want a bit of spacing, I'm
gonna say progress. Progress bars. Okay, so I'm
just going to do a display grid, we've done that
to columns. And then below that,
I'm going to toggle the progress bar
like that. Here, I'm just going to do
display, flex, flex direction to column Okay,
I want them to be one after another. So that's
what we're using the column and then I'm going to
select the progress title, drug title. Here I'm
just going to give it you know, text transform
text transform to uppercase, so
I'm gonna put it into uppercase
font weights, I'm gonna put it the five
hundreds Okay, so after the progress title,
I'm going to say progress progress
container, the progress icon class
display flex align items to center so in
there we have a prompt text as or prog text
so the text is never just a great color. Okay,
now let's save and let's see what we have so far.
Okay, so there it is a one next to this
text here to have a progress bar okay. So
something is missing here my skills Okay,
nothing is missing you just need to stop this h4
Okay, so now we just need to
let me check h4 stat title.
Ah, okay, so we have a class was that title
for the h4, I'm gonna say starch. Starch that's
tight. Okay, it's not there. Although we need
to start that later. Okay, so now we need to
do the progress bar now. So if the progress
text after that we have the progress.
So the actual progress I'm gonna say width
with one or 2%. So for this one height,
it's going to be point four, five for this
for the height, and then the background color.
I'm going to put a position of relative because
save this Alright, let's see what we get. So
there it is. So that's our progress bar. But we
need something also inside to show the progress,
the actual progress. Okay, so that's how we have
that span inside that inside the progress.
So, so the span is going to be responsible
for filling in the width. So this pan is going
to be a person of absolutes. That's why we did
percent relative here. So left and top is going to
be zero, and then the height is going to be 100%.
Okay, and then the background color is going
to be the secondary color the green one.
But if I set the width here,
for say, maybe with 60%
As you can see, is there. But if I want to
create more items here, if I see a progress
bar, I'm gonna say 12345, I'm gonna save
when I go, as you can see, they all have the same
width, I want them to have like different width
according to maybe different programming language
or something, a different width. So to do that,
we need to give each individual
progress bar, I'm gonna redo this undo.
Okay, so you see this pan, it is a class
of HTML. So whatever language you're doing,
give it a class of that. And then after this
pan, and then you target each individual language
and give it a different width according to
whatever data you want. So in this case is 90%.
Okay, so now it's going to be in safe, because
I didn't save. Okay, so now it's going to be
90%. As you can see, it's 90. And they want to
do another programming language when I copy the
progress bar. So this is the actual progress bar
that I need to copy multiple times. I just need
to change the class names for the progress span.
Okay, so this fan, I just need to change the class
name and then put a div to a different width.
So in this case, I'm just going to paste in the
the stats. That does ups. I'm just going to paste
in the stats. Okay, so progress bars. That, so
there, so now I've done the
progress bars off camera.
So now we should have like six
different progress bars. Okay, there.
But now there's something missing. Look, this
progress bar progress bar has, they have different
class names. Okay, so I'm just gonna copy those
class names here and give them different width.
So here we've done the HTML already. And
that's gonna paste in HTML, CSS, JavaScript.
So make sure your width, so our full
name, so this one should be 90%.
Actually, at, for me, I've put HTML
280. And then the rest of the classes,
it's up to you what you decide to do with
them. So as you can see, now we have different
now we have different progress bars.
So it's only a matter of giving a
different class name to a different progress bar,
because we're using a grid. Okay, so each progress
bar, I can give it a different class name, you
can actually do as many progress bars, as many as
you want. It's not limited to six was it's a grid,
right? So you can do as many as you want. As many
as you want. It's up to you. Okay. So now, let's
do this title here. Why did we name this title?
I'm going to collapse the progress bars. So we see
what we're looking for. So the is called stats.
So it's actually stat stats title.
Okay, so this chair tighter. On this to be
independent, I wanted to be outside of this
container. I'm just going to go outside. I'm just
gonna do that down here. I said text transform
to uppercase. Then I'm going to give it a
font size of 1.4. Rem and then text align
to say Enter. And then I'm going to do
padding. Top and bottom is going to be
3.5 3.5, left, left and right zombies
zero. And then position relative.
Because I want to create a before so the
element inside it. So I'm going to say before.
So you know the drill. Before we've done this
before, I'm going to say content, set content
to an empty string. And then left, I'm just going
to set some properties here, left 50%, top 0% When
I give it a background color of gray, and
then I'm going to center this on the x axis.
So my say transform, Translate X and then
minus 50%. to center this on the x axis,
okay, now I'm going to go to the
Okay, so now we've title my skill.
Okay, but we need their border.
Actually, I think we need a border.
So we can give this title maybe a border
border top or something. I don't know.
Yeah, let's do a border. I think
that's that's the better way to do it
actually not a border. So this before so the
element is responsible for that. content. So
we just need to give this a width with is there
percent of absolutes let me inspect to see why
it's not showing. Inspect before pseudo elements.
says is there transformation Translate X? Left 50%
The know why the O is height? bone color.
I think this there's something wrong with the big
one color. Background Nope, it's not showing still
content empty string. Person relative
have no idea why it's not showing. Save
everything again. I'm gonna inspect.
It's interesting. Let me try
to redo the background color.
Still, it's not working. I think I've
done something wrong somewhere. And before
so check your naming.
Start tighter.
I'm just trying to figure out why the let me
see if I have this variable. Right? It's there.
Okay, let's do something else. I'll figure I'll
figure out later what's going on. Why it's not
working. So let's do something else. So now we
need to do the timeline. So I was wanted to put
like a line here onto the title, but for some
reason, it's not showing. I'll try to figure
out why. It's not showing later on. Let's focus
on the syllabus. That's I'm going to collapse.
So now we need to do the timeline. For the
timeline. I'm just going to say dot timeline.
Okay, so for the timeline, we're just going is
going to be a grid. So same same as will same
stuff we've been doing. So it's going to be a grid
and We're going to have two columns of the grid.
So we're going to have a timeline, Timeline Item.
Okay, so it's a grid item. So Timeline Item.
So anytime I make a Timeline
Item and when, say dots timeline
icon, so we're going to have an icon as well. And
then icon is going to be like a briefcase icon.
I'm going to pull that you can go to folder
Summon, look for any icon that you're looking for.
And then P dots to timeline to ration. And
then here you can put like a duration of when
you started working for a company and stuff,
blah, blah, blah. And then we're just going to
have an h five with the span inside. And then a
paragraph with some random, remedied some texts.
Okay, that's it. That's it for the
Timeline Item. That's pretty much it.
Okay, we just need to add the title above the
timeline. Here. We can just say, my timeline.
Okay, so let's save. Let's see what we got. So
there it is. So my timeline, so we just need to
determine item to do a grid for this terminal
item. Okay. So to do that, we just need to
go to the styles. Main here,
I'm just going to say timeline.
Okay, so dots timeline. And when I say display
grid to columns, we've been doing this,
so my gonna waste your time rewriting. And then
I'm going to say dots timeline, Timeline Item.
So for the terminal an item, I'm going to say,
for suitability because I'm going to person
absolute the icon, coding left, padding left
is going to be three REM, left three rem and
then a border of one pixel border left. So I'm
going to give you the border left of one pixel
with a color of gray five, and then I'm going
to toggle the to icon the individual icon,
the actual icon, and I say percent of absolute.
And then I'm going to say left minus 27 pixels,
you can play around with this value to
find whatever value suits your need. Okay,
I'm going to save just show you what I mean. So
I'm going to I'm going to inspect. So this is the
T icon, okay, I haven't
saved yet. Okay, so to icon
Okay, so now, so there is our
icon, okay, so you can sort of
play with this value the left left value to
see whatever you need. So the minus 27 was the
value that I found to be better. So I'm gonna say
zero and then I'm gonna say give it a building
color of secondary and then I wanted to be
rounded so width and height must be the same
for it to be rounded and then a border
radius of 50% make sure it's rounded. Okay,
so that's why I did width and height as the same.
So there it is. So we just want to set this icon
using flex. So display flex align items and just
for content to center to center the icon Okay, so
and then I just typed it the icon itself and then
give it a font size of 1.3 Ram slightly bigger.
Okay, that's it, the icon should be should
be appearing nicely. There it is. So now
we just need to style this text and the title.
Okay, so after here I'm just going to duration
to rate shown okay. So to duration
when I give it a padding and the color,
padding top and bottom is going to be point to
ram left and right point six RAM and then border
radius is going to be 15 pixels. I want it to be
rounded and then display is going to be inline
block. Okay and then font
size I want to be smaller.
font size is going to be point eight RAM and
then We're going to text transform uppercase,
uppercase, and then we're just going to change the
font weight to 500 something, you know, thicker.
Let's now just save everything.
So there is our timeline icon item, I mean, okay,
so we just need to do the title in the paragraph.
So after determined duration, there is an h5.
So there's five, there's only many styling,
the padding, text transform in font
size, just the standard stuff. Okay,
man, I'm going to tell you the span inside
the and then I'm going to give it a color
and the font weight and the font size, just the
standard normal stuff. Okay, after after the f5,
I'm gonna tell you the paragraph, I'm gonna
give it a color of gray, using a variable color.
Gray to reverse the color for that green number
two for the paragraph. So I'm gonna go again. So
there it is, everything is nicely styled. So now
we just need to duplicate this multiple times,
and then change the values. So what you need to
do go back, and then go to determine item need
to duplicate the actual term line item, because
we've done this display grid on this timeline, two
columns. So we just need to duplicate to promote
grid items 12345. And then you just need to change
in the data to whatever suits your need. Okay,
so in this case, I'm also going to paste in some,
some values again, because I don't want to waste
your time me changing these values again and
again. So you can put it to whatever values that
you want. Okay, so Verity, so for me, I've changed
all of the data or just made the random. So for
it to look something, you know, somewhat random.
Okay, so for the line, we'll come back into
the later because I don't know as much showing.
Yeah, I think I'll take a break for
now. I'll see you in the next session.
So now it's time to work on the portfolio's page.
So this one is going to be super quick
and easy. So it's just like a grid.
So let's go to the portfolio section.
Okay, so in this section, we're going to
put some grid items. So mainly, you're going
to put the title, we're reusing the title that
we've created already. And then just put, change
the name to my portfolio just copied the title,
from where we've done it before. And then,
yeah, put it in there. So my portfolio with
the title. And then when I go to the portfolio
page, you can see the title of my portfolio.
There it is. So now, let's do the content.
So for the, I want to have a paragraph here,
P with a class of portfolio, text, just put some
text in the paragraph, like random text. Okay,
in this case, I'm just going to put some random
text. So I'm going to say, dots, what? What Foleo
folios, something like that. And then
here, we're gonna say dot portfolio
item. So in Portfolio item, we're going to
have an image to its image. And then IMG,
image portfolio one. So we have portfolio all the
way to seven, the images. And then below that,
we're going to have below the image, we're
going to have dot hover items. So when I
have the portfolio item, I want to display the
links, where you can download the project if
you if a user wants to. Okay, so I'm going to
have an h3 in there. I'm going to say, Project
source. So the source of the project like the
source code or something, maybe your GitHub links.
Okay, below that, I'm going
to have a class with icons,
of icons. So here I'm going to have an anchor tag
a link. So each link is going to lead to whatever
website you want to. So for example, if I say WWE
does google.com And then I'm going to say Target,
Target. And when I put the target to blank, so it
means open a new page. So if the target is close
to blank, it's going to open a new page. And
then in there, I'm just going to add an icon.
Okay, so you can put as many icons as you
want. So in this case, I'm going to do GitHub.
I want to do GitHub, YouTube. Okay,
GitHub, YouTube and GitHub issue Behance.
That's the icons I'm going to be using. So
now, we have one grid item. So we need like,
six grid items, or more, whatever is depends, it's
up to you. So we're going to have like a grid with
three columns. Because once you have
three grid triggered items per row,
okay, so let's go to the styles, I'm going to
say put folios so that that's the smacking my
way, I'm going to start doing the
portfolio. So I'm going to say dot
portfolio texts. Put text portfolio
text, I'm going to give it a padding,
padding top and bottom is going to be to ram
left and right zero. And then text align.
text align, it's going to be the center. And then
after that, I'm going to target the portfolio's
folios the container. And then I'm going to do
a display grid. We've been doing this for ages
grid template columns. And then we're going to
do repeats and then I'm going to throw in one
fr Okay, so we're going to have three columns and
then grid gap spacing between grid items. So it's
going to be two REM as usual. And then I'm going
to tell you the margin top I'm going to give it
a margin top three RAM and then I went to do
to put folio item the actual individual item,
portfolio item and we'll do percentage
relative and then I'm going to tag the image
inside is the portfolio item and we'll give it a
width 40% Okay in height of 300 pixels and then
I'm going to do object fit to cover and then what
a radius but the rate is going to be 15 pixels
15 pixels, okay? And then below that below
the image I'm going to say dot hover items,
hover items Okay, so with actually before
I do that I've just saved save save save
Okay, so there it is. So it looks
looking nice. Says looking nice.
So image we just need to keep going the
border radius for some reasons didn't apply
border radius 15 pixels we also need to put I
think you need to put this also on the item itself
belief not it's not working let
me inspect this for the radius
doesn't seem to be working
whether re order Oh border radius okay, we'll
fix it later. So now on the have items. Portfolio
item, let me just double check the
class name. So make sure the class names
Okay, that's that's okay. Have items with one
or 2% Right one or 2%. The background color is
going to be the primary and then position
is going to be absolute. So when we have
Okay, so it's not showing yet. Okay. border
radius which will be sent as well. Border Radius
15 pixels. Okay, so they have items positioned
relative. Let me just double check. In inspect
Oh, it's have item have a or is it like that?
Okay, so there is our have item, that's
this, this, this this green color
here. So we're going to center all
of this content here on the center.
So you already know how to do
this, we're going to use flex,
flex align items to center and flex
direction to column. Okay, like so.
And then let's see what we get. It's loading.
It's compiling the styles. Sometimes he does
this. Okay, so there is all of the items are
aligned. So now we just need to style the
individual icons. Okay. So to do that, I'm going
to start with an h3, the h3 heading inside the
inside there, and just want to increase the
font size and give it a color in the margin.
So the first is going to be 1.5
RAM, and a margin bottom of 1.5 Ram.
Okay, and then after that,
after the three, target the
icons, I want to say I wanna, I want
to align the items as all display flex,
to center. And then the icon, individual
icon, I want to give it a background color
of the primary. So width and height has to be
same for us to be to round two measures rounded
border radius, 50%, width and height must be
the same. So whatever width and height you put,
mesh was the same for us to make sure the icons
are nicely rounded. So for example, like this,
the icons around it, so we just need to center
this in the middle with Flex. Okay, so you're
in order to do that, and then we're going to give
it a margin left and right for us to space them.
And then case, it's going to be pointer
and then we're going to do a transform.
Transition, I mean, transition, the
Z for that. Okay, so there it is.
So on, however, we might want to actually want to
change the font size of this icon, these icons,
so I'm going to target the eye. So you can
insert the icon and whatever the I change the
font size and the color to white and then give
the margin, left and right. Of one, like so.
Okay, so when we have this icon, I'm going
to say end. However, what we want to happen,
whenever I just want to change the
background color of the icon, and the actual
icon I tag, okay, so it's just in the color.
So let's see. So now it's changing the color.
So I don't want to display this by default, okay,
I want to only display this when I have this
grid item. So in here, too, I'm going to get rid
of the to get rid of it. So to get rid of it,
I'm going to say I'm going to say go up
at the three I'm gonna give a pastor zero
opacity zero it means I'm gonna like hiding by
stood there minding divisibility who pastor zero.
And then I'm also going to do scale zero,
Transform, transform, scale, zero. Okay.
And then let's do also a transition, the one
we've been using. Okay, so, um, I want to
have a grid item. I want to return these
two default values, opacity and the scale.
Okay, so to do that, I'm just going to scroll
down. I'm just going to say, up here outside,
I'm just going to say portfolio. Portfolio
item. Okay, in hover. So when I have
the portfolio item is the grid item. And
then I'm gonna say dot have items on them to
opacity and we'll set that to one scale also
to one. Okay, so let's see what we got. Okay,
so when I have it's, it's showing, but I just
need to fix this image thing. The image problem
I don't know why it's not working for the
let me just inspect the image. Image with
Uber sent height 30 pixels. Okay, so that's the
parent of the image and then the image itself,
I'm gonna set the image itself height to 100%.
Something fishy is going on.
If you don't set the height
object fit, oh, it's contained, it's supposed
to be cover, smart fault, or a self contained,
contained object fit to supposed to be cover.
So it's going to cover the whole grid item.
Alright, so now it's covering the whole grid
item. So everything works as expected. So now
what we need to do is just duplicate
these portfolio items. Okay,
we can duplicate them by you can
also actually, you know, animate the,
the rotate, but I'm not going to do that
in this video. So let's go to the HTML.
So if we done display grid,
grid, we're displaying three,
three columns. So what I'm going to do now is I'm
just going to duplicate and change the values.
So we have the portfolio images, so the image can
change from portfolio 123445, your you can use
your own images if you want. So you just you
just need to change around the values. Okay,
so portfolio item, I'm going to collapse portfolio
item. And then I'm just going to duplicate this
multiple times 12345 As many as many times as you
want, save, and then go back, we should hopefully
should have more portfolios, and then you just
need to change around these images as well.
Okay, so yeah, I will, I will leave the rest up to
you. Portfolio item. Okay, I'm just undoing this
portfolios. Okay, so I've pasted in the date
with the data change. So I've changed all of the
images. So you just need to do the same as you
just need to change to your own images of your
liking. So I've changed the images. So now yeah,
let's move to the next section, if you remember
this before, so the element was not showing is
because I forgot to do something, when I expect
I forgot to do percent of absolute on the
first element. So make sure you do position
absolute, and then it will show somewhere
down. There it is. So go to the steps
starts tighter. tighter, and then the content
in here to position of absolute. So hopefully
now the line should show. So now we should
ever align. There it is the line here.
Okay. So that's it for the portfolios. Now
let's go for the blocks, the blocks is kind of
similar to the portfolio because it's a great
Azhar is going to be f is going to have,
it's going to have three, three columns.
Okay, so we just need to also go to the blogs,
portfolios, I'm going to collapse this. And when
I go to the blogs, I'm going to say dot blogs,
content content that's like the parent, the main
parent container. So in there, I'm going to paste
in the title and then the title, just change it
to my blog. So we've created this title before.
So it's inside the header,
that's where actually inside the
the about section, that's where we first
created this title here. So just copy the
name main title. We've started this without this
title already. So you just need to change the
text. Okay, so hopefully we should have main
title in the blog section. There it is. My blogs.
Okay, so we have the main title. So it's like the
blog section. So now, after the title, I'm just
going to do dot blogs. So in the blogs, I'm going
to do the blogs, that's where I'm going to do all
of the blogs. So in the blogs, I'm gonna do dot
not to block each individual blog. So the blog
is a great item. I'm going to do to be duplicating
this multiple times to create multiple grid items.
Okay, so the blog, I'm going to have
an image img I'm going to say blog one.
Okay, so you can set whatever image you want
to use. So after that, I'm going to do dot
blog, text. And then in there, I'm gonna have
an h4. You can put whatever texts you desire,
anything that you want. And then after that,
we're going to have a paragraph with random texts
as well, like that. Okay, that's it for
the blog item, we just need to start this,
there isn't much to it, we just need to start
this and then we can go to the next section. Okay,
so we just need to go to the styles
and just get started with the blogs. So
portfolios, portfolios, and then
here, just going to do blogs section.
Okay, so here, we can do dots, blogs. So the
blog is going to be a grid display. So that's
the parent of each individual blog, grid. So in
here, we're just going to have three columns.
So the standard stuff we've been doing
before, and then each individual blog,
we're going to have a percentage relative. And
then background color is going to be gray five.
And we're going to give it a border radius of five
pixels to make the corners be rounded, you know.
And then we're going to give it a
box shadow, you can use the variable
or you can use this one. Okay, so one
pixel, one pixel, one pixel on the Y,
one pixel on the x and then 20 pixels for the
blur. Okay, and then when we have this blog item,
what do we want to happen? So when we have
one the image to sort of pop out of the
blue container, I'm actually also going to
increase the box shadow or copy this box shadow,
paste. And then I'm just going to increase
like the opacity of the box shadow from
point one to point three. And then after
that, I'm also going to transform this
and then translate why I wanted the blog to go
up slightly Elevate, so minus 50 pixels, I wanted
to go up minus 55 pixels. And then I'm going to
apply the transition. So the one we've been using,
and then inside, inside that one we have
also going to target image. So image filter,
filter, I'm going to do grayscale, I'm going to
do zero. Okay, and then what to do transform,
translate, actually, the scale learn to
scale the image. I want it to be larger.
So one by 1.1. So the image the normal scale
is one, so I want it to be slightly larger by
point one. Okay, so it's like 10 larger by 10%.
I don't know. Yeah. 10%. Okay, so, and then,
we're also going to do a boxer. We're going to
do a boxer for the image. So the main boxer is on
the y axis, which is four pixels. So we wanted
to show a lot of shadow on the Y axis. Okay.
So now, let's save let's see what we got so
far. When I go to the blog section seems like
there's a glitch somewhere. Yep, there
is a glitch. I don't know what happened.
Plugs. Me refresh this. I don't know
why it's glitching. Okay, plugs.
That's, that's odd. Let me double check
the class names. Blogs. Blog item.
Oops, plus content. I don't know
what's going on. Okay. I think
I know what's going on. Go back.
Check the classes ID. So the ID blogs.
Class. Oh, this class name is
matching our blog class name.
So get rid of this class name wrong. We're
not going to use it. So get rid of that.
I don't know why this. This class name didn't
affect that. Portfolio. thing. You can get rid of
these class names. We're not gonna use them. Let's
see if it's gonna affect anything. Let's save.
Yep, nothing affected. Yep, nothing affected here.
Okay. Yeah, so We didn't use those class
names up here. So just get rid of them.
I think we're using this about class names.
So leave that for now. If it's affecting
it, or if it's affecting something, it means
we're raising the class, just get rid of it.
Okay, so now, not glitches. So there it is. So
the image sort of like pops out of the grid item,
like, boom, boom, but we need to
make it transition nicely smoothly.
So to do that, let's go back to the styles.
So after the have effect, after we finished
with the hover, we need to now style the image or
sort of the hover. So I'm going to do image with
100%. And then I'm going to do height 300
pixels. And then I'm going to do object fit.
Object fit to cover to cover and then what
to do, I want to give you like corners
on the top, top right and top left was a
border, radius top, top. Border Radius, top.
Radius.
Well, the radius top, top left, so top left is
going to be serpents top left, just give like
five pixels. And then we're going to do top right
five pixels. So let's save let's see what we have.
So there it is, we have a border top,
top right and left. So there it is.
Okay, so now we just need to tell the give
it a transition and give the the filter.
So when we have the filter. We need
to affect the filter now actually,
so future one of the present. So here
we said that filter to grayscale zero,
and then he has like one or 2% and then a
transition to make a slow transition slowly.
Oops. Okay, so it's gonna transition slowly.
So it's grayscale. Okay, when we have,
it's going to go to one or two go to zero.
So by default, the grayscale is 1%. When
you have the grayscale is going to go to zero,
which is the you know, black and white. Okay,
so the image is sort of like pops out. Okay, so
after the image, I'm going to do drudge blog.
Text. So for the block text, I'm
going to give it a margin margin top,
actually margin top. So for the margin
top, I'm going to do minus seven pixels.
So you can play around with this value,
we can try to find any value that you
see fit. But for this one, I'm fine,
like seven pixels minus seven pixels
to be a good value. And then I'm going to do a
padding top and bottom is going to be 1.1 REM.
Actually padding, no top and bottom around
everything. So I want to block texture padding
around for 4.1 Ram. Let me show you what I
mean. So as you can see here, there's like
spacing around the text. So that's the padding
1.1 Ram. Okay, so that's that. So now let's,
I'm just going to do a border. A border top. Okay.
So I'm going to do but a top like this, it pixels.
Okay, so that's the border. So whenever
the border gets covered, because that's
the effect we're looking for. And then there's
like a nice shadow. Okay, seems like when I
have the shadow on the x axis is too much, I
might want to get rid of that. box shadow X,
Y four pixels. So on the X, I'm going to set
to zero on the x axis or on anything on the X.
Okay, since you didn't make any changes, but
you can always reduce the blur. Maybe to 15.
Okay, so can we just a blur to 15
Yeah, I think it looks good. So now
let's tell the text. Okay, so now in the
block, blocks text and we're tied to the h4.
I'm just going to change the font and the
color. So the font and then when we have
when we have I'm going to set the color to
green So it's just color, color secondary.
Okay, like that. And then the after
the edge for a monetary the paragraph,
I'm just going to set the color as well. Color
to gray, gray too, and then give the line height.
So the spacing of the lines to RAM. And
then we're also going to do padding bottom
of our RAM. So just to give it a bit of spacing.
So now let's save. Okay, so that's our blog item,
it's fully styled. So what we do, all we need to
do now is just to populate the blog items. Okay.
So to do that we've been doing this forever.
So we just need to get this grid item,
and populate this multiple times, to whatever
amount of blogs that you're looking for.
In this case, I'm just going to put them multiple
times and change the values and images to whatever
values that suits your need. So just populate
this multiple times, and change around the values.
Okay. And then I'm just going to put like my
own values, I don't waste your time doing this
on screen. So I've done that now. There it is. So
now I've different content for the blogs items.
Okay, yeah, that's it for the blog. Let me now
let's move on to the contacts. So did the contact
section, we're going to have two sections left
and right, because we're going to do some inputs.
Okay. So for the contact section, go down
here. And then we're going to do the title.
So we're going to put a title, as usual,
but first I'm going to do DOJ contacts
container. And then I'm going to paste in the
title. So the title is going to be contact.
If you still don't know we did this title
from the beginning in the header, so we're
just reusing that title component over and over
just changing the values. Okay, so and then I'm
going to do dots, contact, contact content,
container, contact content container. Okay,
so we're going to have just left contacts, and
then we're going to have left and right contacts.
Left and right contacts left.
This one is right. Contacts.
Okay. So let's start with the left
contacts. Okay, so the left contacts
we're going to have an h4 in the paragraph first.
So h4 in the paragraph. So the h4 says contact me
here and the paragraph just a random paragraph.
Okay, and then below that, we're going
to have like another div code dot
contact info. So in the contact
info is going to have some icons,
a lot of icons for for the contact info. Okay,
so I'm just going to say, touch Contacts. Item.
Okay. And then in there, we're going to
have an icon, dots icon, conduct item,
and then we're going to have an actual icon.
So in here, I need location icon. And then
below the location, I am going to say location.
Okay, I'm going to save let's see what we have.
So when I go it says location, see there's an
location item here icon. There's a location item
icon I mean, before the location text, okay, so I
want to have multiple icons and text next to it.
Okay, so to do that, we just need to
duplicate the contact it or multiple times
and change around the icons. Okay. So
in this case, actually after the icon
and when to your paragraph. And when I say London,
United Kingdom. Okay, so we're still in the
contract item. So we just need to duplicate
the contract item multiple times. Okay,
for us to have multiple multiple items.
Okay, so I'm just going to
paste in some content items,
I don't want to waste your time
doing this conduct items on screen.
So conduct item past that in multiple times
change the icons and change the information
to whatever you want. So there it is.
So these are the icons that I'm using.
Okay, so we've done that. So now let's to
start doing the styles. I'm going to say
contact contact section. Okay, so let's
start on the contact. So for the contact,
we're going to do display
flex, dots, contact content
container. Okay, so we're going to do display flex
when everything will be next to each other. Again,
padding top 3.5 3.5. Okay, then we're, first
we're going to target the left content.
So deaths left's contacts, actually.
Contacts. So for the left contacts,
I'm going to do flex to, I want it to be smaller
than the right one. So the right one, I'm
going to set that flex to one to make it cover the
main space. So now this is such a smaller, it's
because I haven't put content on the other one.
So that's why it's, it looks weird at the moment.
Okay, so now let me put the content first. So
for us to see how things are progressing, let me
put all of the content, all of the content that
we need. Okay, so below the conducts item here.
After so after the contact
info after the contact info,
I'm going to put another div. So this one
is going to be contacts. Contacts. Contact,
I cons. So once you have like some icons that
are gonna lead to social to social media, okay,
so in here, I'm going to say, dot contacts.
icon. So this one is contact icons. And then
this one is contact the icon, okay, like that.
And then we'll do an anchor tag that's going to
lead us to whatever platform WWE dot face book
facebook.com on depends where wherever
you want to go to just put a link there.
Okay, and then here, I'm just going
to paste in your Facebook link.
And then make sure you put the target to blank if
want to open that to a new tab. targets to blank.
Okay, so that's the icon for Facebook.
I'm gonna paste in the rest of the items.
Okay, so we have Twitter and stuff. Okay, that's
it for the left side. So we just need to go to the
right side. So the right side is going to have
like a form. When I say form, towards contact,
contact form form like that. Okay, so in
here, we're just going to have some inputs.
And whenever div called input control dot input,
control, okay, like that. And then we're going
to have two inputs. The first one is input text,
and then we're going to is going to be required.
required and then placeholder to a
placeholder is going to be like your name.
Okay, so we're also going to do another input. In
order, we can just duplicate the one that we have.
And the other one is going to be email.
Your email. Okay, like so. So now we just need
to duplicate this input control one more time.
Actually, not one more time. Here, I'm gonna
get rid of email. Here I'm just gonna say
In the sub type subjects, I don't know
enter, subject, subject, like that. And then
I'm just going to also do input control.
And then this one is going to be text area,
text area. And then you can leave the name
blank if you want. And then the columns,
I'm going to do 15 and then eight rows. Like so.
Okay, so that's pretty much it, we just need the
button, the button that we've created before. And
when I put it in a, I'm going to put in a class
code dot submit btn I'm just going to paste
in the button that we've created before.
So it's called main button, we've done that
created our button before visit multiple times.
I'm just going to save this to
see what we have to enter into.
Okay, so there we go. That's why we got
so now we just need to get started with
styling this stuff. So go to the styles.
Okay, so left contacts. Where
do you dots? Right? Contact.
Okay, so right contact. And then for the
right, I'm going to say flex, three. So this
one flex two, and then this one is flex three.
So there you go. So this occupying more space.
Okay, flex three, and then margin. Left is
going to be something like maybe three RAM.
Okay, and then below that I'm
going to do input. Control.
Control the input control class. Okay, I'm
going to do margin, that margin top and bottom
is gonna be 1.5 REM literal zero. And then
I'm gonna target the inputs inside the Okay.
And do border radius to the pixels. And then I'm
going to do font weight. font weight inherits
one size Eretz font family. Inherit,
okay, and then I'm going to do a padding,
top and bottom is going to be point eight RAM.
Left and right is going to be one point while RAM,
you can change these values to put values
that you want. Outline, there'll be none.
Border, I'm gonna give it to none as
well. But if none, and then we just need
to do a background color and the width of one
represent background color and color of white.
And then resize one to be
none. Because we don't want the
form and the texture to be resized. So I'm going
to put a comma and then text area as well on the
text area to have this tells us Oh, I'm going to
save, save everything. Let's see what we have.
So there it is. Okay, but I want this your
name and your email to be next to each other.
Okay, so I want these to be next to each other. So
to do that, I am going to give the input control
this one, another class called input control.
Actually, I just do like this input control two.
Okay, so input control two
after the input control.
That's where I'm going to tell that when to do
display, flex, okay, and then I'm going to say
last child, the last input, the last
input, I'm going to give it a margin left.
margin left of 1.5 from the last child. Okay,
let's go and see what we got. There it is. So
last child, this one is going to have a margin
left of 1.5. So everything looks equal like this.
Okay, so we can actually increase this font
weight or this text to maybe something like
500 making more thicker, or you can leave
it like this. It's up to you what you want.
Okay, oh, you can also text
area, you can say, placeholder
message here like this. And then you can have like
a nice placeholder everywhere if you want like
this, you can do a message here like that. Okay,
so that's that. Now the button, we just need to,
you know, center the button. So to do the button
after the after that after the input control,
you can do dot submit BTN. So just display
flex, display flex, just for content flexed.
Okay, so let's go back, there
is a button is showing nicely.
So now we just need to do the left side.
Alright, so let's go ahead into the left side,
which is just styling the text and everything. So
the left side, where do we get some context items.
Okay, so we're doing flex two for the left,
and then when I toggle the h4 So for the h4
margin top, I'm going to do one ram, font size
to RAM. And then I'm going to do text transform,
transform to uppercase. Okay, after that,
I'm going to toggle the paragraph, I'm going
to give it a margin top and bottom one REM Lanre
line height of two REM, we've been reading this,
we should have done that into a global global
style, but it's okay. Let's keep going.
And we'll do two to contacts. Info. So in contact
info, we have a contact item. That contacts
item if you remember the class names, so just want
to do display. Flex didn't align items to center
justify content space between displace
them. space between let's see what we have.
So there it is the spacing between.
Okay, so now we just need to
target the paragraph inside the quotation there
do p margin. margin, top and bottom is 1.3.
And then zero left and right and then
we're going to override the existing one,
which using the important okay, and then
we're going to do padding top and bottom.
Padding top and bottom is going to be zero and the
left hand writes actually padding everything. Just
padding around everything which one to reset it to
zero. And then we're overriding with the important
keyword. Okay, so now everything we have a point
three margin, top and bottom. Okay for each item,
so there's like a margin top 3.3 Ram. Everything
looks nice. Now we just need to start the icons.
Okay. So, after the paragraph,
I'm going to say dot icon.
Okay, so for the icon, I'm going to say, I'm
going to put them in a grid, display grid,
display grid, and then in grid template columns
I'm going to so I'm putting it in a grid because
I want to restore this. Okay, it's not showing
why because I'll use the grid already. So I'm
just going to show you why grid template columns,
I'm going to say 40 pixels for the first column,
and then one fr for the second column, which
is where the text is for fixes for the icon.
Okay. And then I'm going to go back. So the
reason I did a grid is because I wanted this this
text items to be in line with one another. So if
it's a grid is going to make sure they're aligned.
So when I inspect this, so as you can see, this
one is a grid item. Okay, so each grid item
each item is going to have the first column of
the grid is going to be With the pixels, no matter
what of these grid items, each one is going
to have a column, the first one of 40 pixels.
So hence they're going to have equal spaces
and they're going to live, they're going to
be on the same line, like that. So you get
the idea. And then icon number two, the eye,
the icon inside there, I'm going to say Display,
flex, and then align items, center. And then I'm
going to do font size, the font size, I'm gonna
change that to something like componentry ramp.
Okay, so there it is. So now the icons are
much bigger. So now we just need to do the
these icons here. And then we're done for the
contact page. Okay, so write content, contact,
contact info. So contact info. After the contact
info, we need to do the contact icon dot contact
icon. So if you forgot to know what that is,
is the contact icon. Where is it? Where is it,
where is somewhere down here. So it's this this
container here, contact icon container here.
So that's what we're doing now. Okay, so now we're
doing this container contact icon. So we're going
to do display, flex, display flex, and then I'm
going to do margin top. So for margin top is going
to be sort of like to ram and then we're going to
target the anchor tag in there, which is going to
take us to external websites, I was just
going to do display flex and give it a color,
the center everything, we're doing that with
Flex. And then to make sure it's rounded,
we've been doing this width and height must be
the same. And border border radius to 50%. Okay,
so, my I'm gonna do margin top and bottom zero,
top and bottom, point for RAM left and right.
Okay, and then we're gonna do the
transition, the one we've been doing.
Okay, and then on halfa. When we have this,
we just want to change the background color.
And also for the icon, so we just want
to change the color to the primary color.
Okay, and then after the hover, just in general,
not in the hover, we're going to start the eye
icon, we're going to display flex, align items,
center, justify content center font size 1.3 Ram.
Alright, so now there it is. So now we have a
nice animation. Yeah, that's, this concludes our,
our website. Now we just need to work on the dark
theme, light and dark mode. And then we're done.
Okay, so now I'm just going to go to the
HTML. And I'm just going to put like an
after the controls, I'm going to
do dot, I'm going to say theme
BTN. Here, I'm just going to
put like an, an icon for the two
to toggle the dark mode light and
dark mode. Okay, so theme BTN.
So I just need to style that. And then we're
done. We just need to start the theme BTN.
Okay. So controls
Okay, so after the controls, I'm going to touch
theme BTN. So here, I'm going to do padding,
one ram, and then cursor to pointer. And then the
background. Width and Height must be the same for
us to make them rounded. So I want the button to
be rounded. Okay, like that. And then display.
Flex one to send everything with flex so you
know that what's that is already and then margin.
Top and bottom is going to be point seven rem
and then zero left and right. Muscle going
to paste in the box shadow. You can put this
into a variable so you don't have to do this.
And then I'm going to toggle the
eye. It's only changing the forces
and the color is setting the pointer events
to none. So we don't click it Okay, so
yeah, I mean, you know what I've been. Let's
see what we have, oh, it doesn't exist,
because I've been coping the wrong styles.
Sorry, it's my it's my it's my fault,
I've been looking at the wrong element, I'm going
to do top 5%. Right 3%. And then I'm going to do
with 70 pixels. Same as the height.
So when to make sure this is rounded,
height okay, and then we're
going to do border radius 50%.
So it's going to be rounded, then
I'm going to set the background color
and give it a position of fixed and
then center, the center with Flex. Okay,
like that. So cursor pointer position or fixed.
So now it's gonna be here at the top, right? Okay,
so we want to give it a box shadow. So
like what we did in the text transform.
Okay, so there it is. So I'm going to do when
active. So when I click What won't happen when I
click the button. So I'm going to do transform.
And then I'm going to translate on the Y. So
I'm going to do like minus five fix fixes.
And then the is should be point one second,
make sure it's very low, not high. So if you put
the value too high, you will not see the effect.
So for example, let me say point, five 5.6 pixels,
not six pixels, seconds, point six seconds,
when I click, you won't see the effect. But
when I hold, it takes like points, it takes a
lot of time to do the effects you have to hold,
but on default to be like quick when I click.
So that's why I'm using point one second to make
sure like you can see the effect on click. So when
I click as you can see, like the button is like
moving. Or you can reduce this with not the width,
I mean, the height of translation to minus
three. So when you click, it's like, you know,
translating, okay, so that's that.
So now we just need to do the icon.
So the icon is just changing the font size
and the color. Certainly point of instrument.
Okay, so there it is. So now we just need to work
on the toggle. So it's going to be really quick,
we just need to go to JavaScript. JavaScript after
the session is active, we can say toggle theme.
Toggle theme. And then here we're gonna
say class theme btn is equal to document.
Document. Dot query selector. query selector.
And then here, we're going to do dots
theme BTN. That's the class name we've given to.
So here, I want to say tune button, I'm going
to add an event listener. add event listener,
and then it's going to listen for click. And
then it's going to take in a callback function.
Don't worry, we can do an arrow function.
Now because we're using the this keyword.
Now I'm going to say let's alignment, then I'm
going to say document, the element is going to
be documented body, the body. Okay? Document a
body. And then here, I'm just going to toggle the
class element, which is the body dot class list.
Dot talk toggle. On Click, okay, so we're just
talking one click, I'm just going to put a class
called light mode. Okay, so when I click that,
it's going to toggle this class on and off,
on and off, on and off. So now, let me save.
So let me inspect this. So let's watch out for
the body element. So body here, so we were like
selecting the body element in the JavaScript. So
now when I click this is toggling the class light.
It's editing the class and removing the
class adding and removing the class.
Okay, so now we just need to set the light mode
class. So for the light mode, I'm going to go
all the way app I want to hear, I'm going to
light mode, that's the class name we're talking.
I'm gonna copy all of these colors here.
Okay, and then I'm gonna paste them down here.
Okay, so, for the for the light mode, you
just need to exchange the colors you've used,
for example, the, for the background, I've used
the this dark color here. So don't change the
variable name, just need to change the property.
So I'm going to change it from the black color.
Oops, to the white color. Okay, like
that, and then save the, when I click
the background is going to change to white.
Okay, so it's on this light mode class.
Okay, so you just need to change the values
of the variables to different stuff, just mix
them around. Okay, so for me, I'm using white as
the main background. And then for the secondary,
I'm using a different color, which
is like sort of a pink color.
Okay, for the secondary. So when I toggle
the light, it's going to change to this one,
pink color. Okay, every secondary
colors will change to this pink color.
Okay, so let's keep going. I need
also need to change the text color,
which is white. So for white, think I'm using
some gray number. White, I'm going to paste this
for white, I'm actually using grateful. So
grateful. That's where you're going to put white.
Okay, so this is great for now. So it's just
the variable name is still being used, but you
just need to change the value of it. Okay. Yeah,
let me see if we need to change anything else.
Okay, so lets me go to other components.
Okay, so, yeah, we might need to change some
colors. You know, instead of me going this way,
changing the colors one by one, I'm just gonna
copy, paste the colors that I found worked for me,
you can change these colors to whatever you
want. So you just need to mix them around.
Don't change the variable name, because we've
been using these variables for a reason. So we
just need to change the value of the variable on
a different color mode. Okay, so in this case,
so what works for me is this color, color scheme.
thing really works for me very well.
You can, you know, use a different
color scheme that you want. It's really up to
you. But this one is really perfect for me.
Okay, everything was fine. Yeah, I
mean, this project isn't responsive.
I don't have time to make it responsive. This
is the only time I had to make the video.
But I It depends how many people have requested
in the comments. If you want me to if you want to
see me doing the responsive stuff you can?
Let me know in the comments. And then I'll
consider making a video about it or see how
many people have requested. Yeah, if you have
any questions or anything. Don't forget to ask
me in the comments, or you can send me an email.
Yeah, that's it. Please don't forget to like,
subscribe if you're new house you on the next one.
Okay, so now let's work on the media queries.
Let's try to make this website responsive.
As you can see where we left off,
the website is not responsive at all.
Okay, so we just want to try to make it
adapts to whatever width we're using.
I'm actually using a different projects,
but everything is going to be the same.
Everything is the same the classes everything is
the same. It's just a different folder name. Okay,
so now let's go into the styles and create a
new style. Then put, it's going to be a SASS
partial to create a partial, we're going to use
an underscore and then I'm going to say media
and then dot CSS. So this is a file, this file
is going to be responsible for the media queries.
So I've already kind of looked at screen
work where I need to do some breakpoints.
But if I haven't done that,
you're gonna have to like find
breakpoints which your website your website
is going to start breaking. So I'm going to
start with a smaller screen. I'm going to start
with 600 pixels. So I'm going to do at media
and media screen screen, screen, and then
end. And then I want to say max width,
max width max. So the max width for this
one, I want to put that to 600 pixels.
Okay, so make sure the spacing here is correct. So
if we do like this, it's not going to work. So the
spacing must be correct the same as I've done
it. So make sure everything is correct. Okay,
so I'm going to I'm going to start with the
header. Let's see in the header. So at 600 pixels,
it's 600. So this is the size 600.
I want to have zero padding. Okay,
so as you can see, there's a lot of padding.
If I check to the in the Styles, it should be
padding somewhere. So this padding, right?
Yeah, I'm going to set that to zero.
Okay, so that should be Yeah, so I'm going
to set every every padding here to zero.
So I'm going to say header. I'm
going to set padding to zero.
Okay. So also, the other thing is, for us to use
these media queries, we need to import this file.
So let's go up to import a partial, just do
at import. And then I'm going to say media.
Okay, so you do need to include the file
extension because Sassari knows knows what it is,
it's a special. So you don't need to include
the extension here. As I save, and I'm going
to refresh, nothing works. Because for me the
chords to work, there must always always always be
at the bottom of everything there must be down
here after everything because everything is
executed line by line. So the media queries
must be at the bottom like this. And then you
have to import them here down here instead of up
top. Okay, so now save and save the media. And,
yeah, let's see if submitted the Milica is
working for the header, click the header.
Let's see. So the mediocre is there. So now the
padding is set to zero. For the header. It's
actually direct header derived header content that
we need to also set the padding to zero, I believe
this one, right header pin, right?
We actually need to set that to zero.
Okay, so we're gonna say header, target
header, header, and then dot right. header.
And then I'm going to say padding
zero to that. Okay, so right header,
padding zero. Something weird
is going on parent 00. They're
still fighting, right? Actually, we need to
override everything. So he's important. So
only use this important when it's really important
when you have to. So now we've overridden every,
every all of the styles, all of the pairings.
Okay, so actually, we might want to set this
to to ram, maybe just give it a little bit of
padding around. Yeah, let's say that to ram.
Okay, so we also want to get rid of
these controls here. So to do that,
we can just say, dot controls. That's the class
name. So if I want to double check the selector,
inspect the controls, and find the class name.
There it is controls. Okay, so for the controls,
I must say top, I must add that to auto
to auto auto. And then we're going to say bottom
because the bottom zero, I want it to be to be
at the bottom and then flex direction is going
to be a row now to the default or initial,
you can say initial. And then we're going to say
justify content. And then I'm going to send that
and then we're going to say
left, we're going to give it 50%
Because wanting to be centered. And then we're
going to transfer transform and Translate X
transform and Translate X minus 50%.
Only on the x axis. So Translate X
safe. Let's see what we got. So there
they are. The controls are down here.
And yeah, in there. Actually, we
also need to set the width to 100%.
And then we might also want to give it
a background color to distinguish it be
black with our content. And then
we're going to use gray five,
gray five, that's the wrong color. And
then we're also going to do control
the individual control. So the individual control,
we're going to give it a margin, one, Rem top and
bottom. And then point three REM left and right.
So now they're there, the controls are down here,
instead of up. So when I go over the width is
not there anymore. So now they're there. Okay.
So now the controls will want them to be.
I'm also going to keep styling the header.
Actually any to decrease the theme button
width. So I'm going to say that theme
BTN. So we're going to decrease the width
to 50 pixels, and height 250 pixels as well.
Okay, so width and height 50 pixels. Okay,
so now let's say let me let me just double
check from recording. Okay, so
as you can see now is smaller
on a smaller device. Okay, so we also want to
target the header content, header, content,
or the content, if you don't know what it
is, I'm going to inspect again, to show you
the header content inspect. So this is the header
content. It's a great as you can see, I'm going
to tag that. So the header content, we're going to
change the grid. So we're just going to say grid,
template columns. I'm just going to say one fr
one Fr. One TF. Two columns. Actually, no, no,
no one if I just want fr, because we just want
to have one column instead of two now. So yes,
whenever. So now we have one column. Okay, so
it's to be messy. Say, can bottom six RAM. Okay.
So yeah, so And also, I want, maybe I might
want the text actually to be at the top.
To do that, we just need to, you
know, change these grid items,
change them or swap them around.
So let's just keep going.
So now, I'm going to target the left header, I'm
gonna say left header, I'm going to tag that.
I'm going to say, dot H shape, I'm going to get
rid of that green shape. And then I'm going to,
I'm going to set that display to none. So
I don't want it anymore. So as you can see,
it's gone now. So after the left header, let's
go to the right header. So the right header.
Okay, so for the right header, I'm going to stats,
I want the right header to be at the top. Okay,
so how do we do that. So we just need to change
the grid. So say grid row. It's a grid item. So
I want it to be the starting point of view one. So
I'll show you what that means. So when I inspect
was the grid. So this is the grid,
right? So it starts at one it goes to,
so I want I want this row it was a two
to be at one to be in the first row.
Okay, so we want to also I'm going to set the
width with width, I'll set it to 90%, maybe 90%.
Okay, and then I'm going to
set margin zero auto to center
margin, zero and auto just to center the content.
Okay, now inspect. Okay, so everything was
good. Alright, so now let's, let's keep going.
Mostly want to toggle the name actually. The name,
font size. I'm just going to change that to 2.5
2.5. Ram. Okay, so RAM Linsay.
Let's see is that inspect
Name Font size that media. So this one is not
working. We need to override that with important
so when this was on over can sometimes you might
need to override that. Okay, like that. And
yeah, let's keep going. So after the right
header, we're going to target the header content.
So that header content and then left header.
And then we're going to target the image.
And then we're just also going to set the
margin zero auto width said the same to 90%. And
2%. Okay, so, so there it is. Okay. So
we also need to fix the height actually,
there is an issue with the height inspect header.
Let me see if with a height set on the header. So
the height of the header set height is supposed
to be min height. So minimum height is going to be
100 VH, not the not a fixed height. So we
want to be able to scroll like this maybe.
So, let's go to the header and find header.
Actually, I'm just going to look for 100 VH,
where I've said that valley 100 VH. So here,
instead of height, we're going to set that to
mean height it media query actually
hit media screen and max width,
max width, and then we're going to do 600
pixels. So this is going to be 600 pixels
as to or six and then access under
10 pixels. Max with it media screen.
And max width. Oh, oh yeah, I
don't know why this is not working.
Screen and all this the wrong thing. Cut this,
PR here, like this, and then save. And then
here we're gonna say min height. 100 VH. Okay,
so you can actually do media queries inside of
the element or element that you want to do. That's
when you edit. You can nest only in Sass, that's
when you can do it with normal CSS. You could
not nest like this. Okay, so it's no working.
Cancel this. Just set that to the normal
midnight to the normal header. Okay, so yeah,
now if the mean height, everything works. Okay,
so now let's check other pages. Hope about
now let's go to the About. Okay, so
let's go back to the media queries.
And then we're going to say
dots about, about container.
So let's look at the about container to see
which one it is about, about our session here.
About container, this one, that's what we're
looking at. Okay, so it's also a grid. So we're
going to fix that about container, grid template
columns, we're just going to set that to one Fr.
Okay, and then we're gonna say right about
so the write about, we're gonna say padding top 10
in top. So for the padding top one, we said that
to 2.5 Ram 2.5 Ram, that's what the padding top.
Okay, so I'm also going to set the
right about grid template columns,
or suggested that you want to have
one, only one column to refer to.
Okay, so now let's go to the about okay, you
cannot see it yet. But everything is working,
we just need to get rid of the, the paddings
and everything about container, section two.
Okay, so, here, I'm going to get rid of the
padding. So get rid of the padding. And I'm
just gonna do section select the section. So
for the padding, I'm going to do padding, I'm
going to say to REM 2.5, Rem, left and right, and
then I'm going to override the existing pairings.
Okay, so yeah, as you can see, it looks good. So
if sometimes when you do like this, sometimes it
doesn't override the, the old ones by now you
don't need to do it because we don't need to
override we don't need to do it. Okay,
looks good. So now, let's let's go to the
so we need to write about less here. Let's go to
here we need to do the left side. So let's do the
left about stuff the left about I'm going to say
pending, right? I'm gonna set that to zero. And
then I'm going to target the paragraph in there.
I'm gonna say padding left Mr to zero also Okay.
Okay, everything looks good. All right.
So we also need to target the timeline.
So here after here, I'm
just going to say timeline.
So for the timeline, I'm just
going to change the grid. So
I'm going to do just one fr, I just want to
have one column for the timeline as well.
And then I'm just going to set
the padding bottom to six, REM.
And let's save. Let's see what our timeline
looks like. Yep, there it is. Looks nice.
Okay. So after that, we might also want to do the
stats. Okay, so let's do here after the timeline.
About stats. So in the bus stats,
we're going to tag the progress bars.
Progress bars, remember the class names.
And then we're just going to do one if
that's what you want to have like a single
column, excuse me. Like that everything is good.
Okay, so now let's go to the blog section,
let's see how the blogs are behaving.
These are the blogs. So we also
want a single column in the blogs.
Okay, so about, then we're just gonna say blogs.
So the template columns is just
putting into a single column
and then giving you the padding
bottom from bottom six RAM.
Okay, so now, you see that if I go to
the blogs, now we have a single column.
Okay, everything is good. Okay, so that's that.
Now, we need to also do the context section. Okay,
so, actually portfolios, we missed the portfolios.
So the portfolios that shouldn't be here
portfolios. So we're working on this section.
Now, the portfolios, we want to do similar things.
Like here, so just copy this and put
it here. Okay, so it's quite similar.
Now, so let's see what we got.
portfolios. Reaches everything looks nice.
Okay. Okay, so we might also want to give to
this portfolio as a margin top, but not yet.
Okay, so that's pretty much everything except
the contact. Contact. content, content container.
Okay, so now let's look for the context
content container. Okay, there it is. Inspect.
There is a grid. So let's keep going. We need
to change the flex direction. Flex direction.
We're going safe column. Okay, so contact. So
the conduct was actually flex not a grid. The
contacts container is a flex not agree. So we need
to just change the direction of the flex. Okay,
so yeah, in the, I'm going to tell you the right
contacts. Right. Contact. Okay, so right contacts.
Right contact once a margin left. And we said
that zero, margin left zero. And then I want
to say margin talk was that to 2.5? REM.
So I've experimented with these values off
camera just to make the video quicker. But you can
experiment even more with values if you want to.
Okay. So yeah, that's for the right content. So if
I want to target the inspects one of these inputs,
so I want to take an input control. This
one, I want to tag this. So I'm going to
copy the selector query selector. I'm going
to paste it after the contact container here,
the selector so I'm looking for the input control
number two So input control two. Okay, so that's
the class name, it's actually input, control two
like this, I see two. That's how I've named it.
So, but for this project I'm using I've named a
different so it's input control two like this.
But in the project we need to get in the video
its input control to input control, like see,
I see two. So here I'm using control two.
Okay, I'm just going to say flex direction,
I'm going to put that column so
that's for the input controller too.
And then I'm going to target the last child
of that input control to and we say like this
is a pseudo selector say last child, so I want
to take the last child within the input control
to the last challenge and when I say margin
left, zero and then I also want margin top
Excuse me. margin top so for the margin
top and we'll say that one perfect room
okay, so let's go to the contact. So as you
can see, it's coming Nice. So here inspect this
was to have a margin left and visual so that
is zero. margin top zero it should be zero.
Input left's will contract to this one.
margin left what contractual as child
margin top margin left zero, what's
going on? This this destroy that
inspects again it seems to have seems
to have a margin left for some reason.
Last charge last year last charge
I don't know why it still has the
Oh, I think the media query is not applied.
Let me refresh this again. And then I'm
going to inspect flex direction column okay.
So this is the last child so I'm going to
copy the selector here, copy the selector
cut this and replace with the one you've
copied online from the browser. Okay, save.
Okay, now everything works. I think it's
because of spacing. You actually need to
put the spacing here. So you need to space
here. Space and then yeah, everything work.
Okay, so yeah, everything is working
Nice. Everything's working fine.
So now we just need to mess around with
this title here. Okay, so let's do that.
The title is code. Actually.
Contract item. Contract item
you know, let's make mess with
the title first. That main title.
So here we're talking the h2 and then
font size. We're gonna set that to ram
and also we're going to say select
this pan. Font Size 2.5 Ram.
Okay, and then that PG text 2.5 from as
font size like that. Now, save. Now, let's
see what we get. Yep. So there it is.
I think we just need Omani to increase
the this is a bit desperate to three round
Okay. Yep, I think So you can kind of mess around
with this the size of the font size of that
yeah so at this size is this media
query the breakpoint looks really nice.
So you can kind of work out what breakpoints
you need to make changes you know, I mean, so
in this case, we need to fix this inspect.
Left header. Left header, we need to set
the header content height need to
set min height think min height.
Or we actually need to set the height to
100 VH for that for the header content.
Okay, yes, everything comes nice to our
breakpoint, breakpoint, sexual min height,
header content we need to set min height here.
min height. Okay, so let's go to find the
header content. Header content better content
content content. So we need to set a min height
here. min height, we'll set that to 100 VH.
Okay, so yeah. So now here we can enter, try
to find some breakpoints, which we also need to
you know, kind of mess
around with the styles a bit.
I think here the title it is
a margin, which I don't want.
Right header which is a padding, which I don't
want. So here we should look for right? header.
Header new. So here, it should be
actually said parent 00. refresh that.
Something weird is going on?
Yes, it is zero and important.
Okay, so yeah, so now, everything should
work nicely. You can work with the font size,
you can reduce the font size at a certain
width, you can use the font size percentage.
Okay, so everything looks good. So
we just need to work on a way to,
let's say, can find like a break point
where everything starts to break and start,
you know, doing some media queries there. For
example, I'll do another breakpoint maybe.
Okay, so I kind of contact when does contact
says to break. Okay, so for this contact,
it breaks away too early. So I'm
going to do another breakpoint
for the contact. So here, I'm going to say it
media I'm actually going to copy this copy this
paste to here. And then here I'm
going to change this to 1432.
Okay, so for experiment with this values of
camera, so here the contact breaks too early.
So I'm going to copy the contract every everything
over the contract and when to cut it. And then I'm
going to do that early in this address size
at 1432 of paste the contract stuff here.
Okay, so when I go to the contacts, now
it's tasked to you know, adapt early nicely.
So we can also mess with the padding of the
section. So in this case, I'm going to mess
around with the padding of the sections as well.
And once a section I'm going to do padding,
top and bottom. I'm going to do seven Ram
11 Ram left and right. Okay, so refresh.
Something weird is going
on. Section. Okay, max width
Let's inspect to see
the body Oh, the body is a class of
sessions. So the body is inheriting the
I mean, the header is
inheriting this section styles.
So in the header, we need to get rid of that.
So, here, I'm going to say header padding, zero.
Okay, so we actually need to override because the
head is actually inheriting the section class.
Okay, so yeah, there it is. So now when I,
you know, start to decrease everything is
going slowly, but it's gonna, it's gonna work.
Okay, so let's see.
Okay, so that's for the contact section,
I'm going to do another media query.
I'm just going to do a media query
just to sort of subdividing out.
So at this size, this section, I know that this
size, I'm actually going to put another size maybe
1070. Or, Yeah, let's do this size 1070
pixels here. And we'll talk about container.
So that's the about and then grid template
columns, I'm going to set that to one Fr.
And then in the I'm going to tell you the write
about I'm just going to change the padding top to
confirm. To confirm, so that's
for the parent top in the
about, so that's 1000 pixels here, there
it is. So everything is going to flow nice
in a single column. Okay, and also I'm
going to target the main title in here.
I'm gonna say main Titan, x two. And
then font size. For REM span, and then
for REM safe Okay, big Tex. Size facility for
muscle. Let's see how that's going to look like.
Okay, we're gonna increase that to maybe 4.5 frame
or 645. Yeah. Okay. I think I'll stick to 4.5.
Okay, so that you can, you know, sort of give
like a margin top of the, the content here,
you can give it a margin top to specify between
this title here. So it's kind of up to you.
Okay, so let me check. Let's do
the portfolio show. portfolios.
Let's do grid grid template columns. Let's just
do one fr, one Fr. So this is the two columns.
Okay, so now we have two columns of portfolios.
Let's do the same thing for the blogs can
duplicate this and chain these two blogs.
Okay, so the blogs also going to
have two columns. Okay, like that.
Okay, so two columns for the blog's? What do we
need to mess around with again? So yeah, actually,
let's do one more media query. You can admit me
as many media queries as you want for anything
and you can customize and change everything that
you want to change. So here, I'm going to do 9970
pixels, nearly 70 pixels. So here the section
section. I'm going to change the padding
something top and bottom 07 Ram, six RAM
Clifden, right. Like this. Now let's say
let's decrease the width. Okay, there
it is. Everything looks nice. Okay.
So we also need to mess with this
stuff here. Windows is just to break.
You know, I think I might actually
want this to happen early.
But what we did with the content, the
header content header, theme button
had a content lift header about. Okay, I think I
want this header stuff cut to happen early. So I'm
going to put that in the nine in the in 970. And
we put that in there. Okay, so it happens early.
Okay, like that. So I think that it makes a lot
of sense for it to happen early than anticipated.
Yeah, I think that makes sense. So we also need
to do the same thing for the controls as well.
Controls, cut the controls. Cut that. And then
we're going to make it happen early. So you can
you know, mess around with the values and
see what where you want to start, you know,
affecting your media queries. So I think
this idea of soldering that at this size.
Okay, I might also want to specify around these
ones the controls. So each control thing might
reimagine. I'm going to say to ram for
this one. Okay, control margin to ram.
Okay, to ram seems to be small. Let's see, six is
not working for some reason. Let's override this.
Still not working? We'll see why. Control.
Margin. Oh, it's top and bottom is supposed to be
left and right. So it's supposed to be the other
way around. So let's bring it back to to ram is so
this is top and bottom. This is left and right. So
I want to apply the margin left and right. Okay.
So, there it is. So top and bottom, actually,
I'm going to increase that to maybe 6.6. Okay,
so everything's going to look nice like this.
Okay, so yeah, you can you can kind of mess
around with everything, just to kind of look
for breakpoints where you want to, you know,
affects your, your styles and elements, whatever.
I'm going to reduce this to 1.5. Or one actually,
yeah, you can kind of mess around with the media
queries, the breakpoints, like where your stuff
starts to break. That's where you start, you know,
doing the media queries, you can just create a
break point for that. For the blogs, the breaking
quite early. So it's something as some
certain size, you might want to, you know,
put the blocks in a single column. Okay. So yeah,
actually, I'll do one more. I'll do one
more. I didn't want to make this video long.
I'll just do one more now. And then that's
it. So let's do let's do 700 pixels.
So in here, this section, I'm going to change
this section here, just copy this section.
Here, we're just going to change the padding. So
that's two three. Okay, so we also want to do the
about section about stats, let's do the stats.
And then we're going to do the progress bars.
Actually, I think we've already done the
progress plus let me double check about
progress bars. Yeah, I think yeah, we
might want to progress bars. Progress bars.
I think instead of doing the progress bars later,
progress, progress bars here, instead of doing it
here, copy this cut, and then we do it here early,
rather than later. So here we're just changing the
display of the Progress bars. We're
going to have them into a single column
at 700 Something big they certainly pixels.
Okay, so searches. Everything looks nice.
I think yeah, everything looks nice. So the
timeline, it gets affected 600 pixels. So,
I mean, I think everything is really nice now
if the idea of how to do the media queries,
and everything, we can also kind of
mess around with the main title here.
So we just need to, you know, set the
font size, maybe to a smaller one.
And then maybe we can change the texture so
the big text to a different font size so you
can kind of mess around with the styles to see
what kind of styles you're looking for. And what
what, I don't know any size, you
can do any media query for inside so
yeah, I think that's it for this video.
So if you've learned a lot of stuff,
please don't forget to subscribe, comment, and
share the video. I'll see you on the next one.